there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock
hello individuals it is episode 153
yeah and I've already started yeah
seriously we've been working we're
trying to get ahead so we've like
already recorded a bunch of stuff today
and you guys know how if that goes yeah
I've been drinking for more than two
hours I'm already revved up the
entertainment will start soon I'm
already forgetting words Ginny's having
a like pasta remember people's names and
yeah been talking about Johnny Carson in
tonight's show yeah I told him it's like
and I might have mentioned this on the
show before but cuz we were talking
about Johnny Carson on like another
thing that we just recorded and I was
like do you know that this is maybe
something you don't know but it's like
every time I go to push the record
button
I hear the Johnny Carson theme song in
the back of my head he was the man yeah
and so so was headed I don't know why I
said Ed McMahon yes the man to you could
tell that it was Ed was blasted yeah he
was blasted watch everyone this shows us
this show is a 17 1970 style show we're
gonna give you entertainment and
information and yeah we drink during
this go ahead and have a drink half
about half of you who listen drinking
the same stuff you get a drink ask me
what it is I'm freakin I'm making the
same drink that I drink the ten equal
parts it's equal parts tequila usually
ripples on do I like reposado tequila
you know what I mean
which but you can use silver and gold
alright there's one part that one part
guava nectar which you get that like in
the in the import international
international session okay get that
guava and then you put pineapple
their pineapple juice yes third third
heavy ice this isn't Germany this is a
tropical [ __ ] drink okay yeah it's
like for Monday because here seriously
heavy ice stir it man it's just [ __ ]
beautiful i call it a lord
cool cool calm the lord of mexico it'll
make you want to tear someone's house
[ __ ] right exactly approved in mexico
i years i hear my buddy in [ __ ] TJ he
he loves it he loves it you know this is
a good Mexican drink I just have Mexican
American drink I just have a boring ass
screwdriver like usual cuz I love my
body and I'm tannin bar okay today
you'll be listening to what are we doing
the Dayton alright now this was actually
a really cool suggestion that I kind of
like spun off in my own direction one of
our British listeners um a long time ago
requests it's like why don't you do
something about this serial killer known
as the blackout Ripper yeah I know a
little bit better yeah and like I didn't
really know a lot about that so like the
more I looked into him like wow that's
like a fascinating case and it happened
during World War Two now while I was
researching that I came across a similar
crime which also happened during World
War two just in a different country and
this guy was called the brownout
strangler okay so we got two key so we
got two different cases they're gonna
talk about very similar situations
similar type of thing going on so I
thought well let's just throw a bunch
they're both working they both um I
don't think so like I said I might have
I was gonna um you know shout out like I
said if you didn't notice our matinee
show yeah you know we kind of changed
the format of a little bit so we could
review movies that had gone straight to
VOD like Netflix or or that didn't play
in our theaters and stuff like that cuz
we you know my car went tits up and yeah
you know I can't afford to get it fixed
and I gotta save up money to get another
one so I'm in the car Jenny probably go
half on it with me yeah so we don't want
to get Cadillac Jenny's like I can't
afford no Cadillac I think we can afford
a Cadillac let's see what it is
we'll see Cadillacs [ __ ] old man car
yeah cuz I do all the drive and Jenny
doesn't even like to drive
I was I was in a wreck that's why ya
know we're still getting t-shirts
returned because we [ __ ] on the
postage but it's okay go send up who is
this Jenny tell them we'll send it back
to him okay this is Natalie now so yeah
we're gonna send it back wait yeah I'm
actually kind of glad that I'm getting
them back because won't happen again I
didn't what yeah I didn't want anybody
to get them with postage do something
like oh thank goodness okay so I think
most of them came back down so that
might be the last one to come back and
I'll just send it out but you'll get
your shirt in a bit probably send it out
tomorrow
and put the right amount of postage on
it because I guess we [ __ ] that out so
yes you know we sent it as an envelope
instead of sending it as a package but
to me that's a [ __ ] envelope well
it's called a padded envelope but
apparently I mean the lady of the post
office she was like yeah it's only an
envelope if it's just paper but as like
other [ __ ] in there like headings and
it's a package so I was like alright
fair enough whatever I can see how that
goes alright so on today's show like I
said we're gonna be talking about two
crazy [ __ ] who during World War
two on separate continents when there
were war conditions blackouts brownouts
what-have-you they decided to take it
upon themselves to believe me like hey
I'm going to butcher a bunch of women in
a very short time cuz it's dark out and
no one will catch me although the
spoiler alert they both got caught
almost immediately because they were
idiots this is the world war two era and
of course there was a draft on which
means that the armies of all these
nations are not being very choosy about
who gets in and you're gonna suck up
some serial killers that's just gonna
happen well in a population of yeah
they're not men largely I mean there's
not a lot of female serial killers not
none of this type anyway you suck up a
couple million men there's gonna be a
serial killer or two in there at least
one yeah whose military cover the
military system and the and the
environment of warfare as a cover yeah
for what they're for what they do and
that's what this story's about yeah now
there's a new sexual predators man
sexual predators under the cover of
warfare [ __ ] you up and [ __ ]
raping women bad [ __ ] doing it probably
in uniform and then the army gets all
the labor
tear
terribly [ __ ] disgrace these need to
be humped by the neck until they're dead
they were good far as I knew both of
them but yeah that's yeah these these
dues it's weird like the first guy
The Blackout Ripper in a way is kind of
like um weirder to me because he didn't
have a history of it you know he came
from a good family and I think there was
nothing like in his past it would
suggest that he would just suddenly be
like oh it's dark I'm gonna start
killing people um the second guy
brownout strangler that he was kind of a
different situation like he kind of had
a shitty family and so I could you know
and there was like his brothers were no
I'm just saying but it's more
understandable because he had some [ __ ]
go with leading up to it whereas the
first guy it's just seemed like normal
normal normal and then BAM you know what
I mean which to me is always weirder an
abusive environment will create an
abusive person exactly yes and that's
definitely I think what happened in the
second case but in the first case I'm
not really sure what his [ __ ] problem
was he must have just been had like
[ __ ] mental problems or sexual
problems I'm not you know sometimes you
know man I just have these sexual
problems I you know I just have to tie
you up yeah yeah okay I talked about
Dennis I'm gonna get back to my [ __ ]
cool I'm sure well the drunker you get
I'm sure Dennis won't have to like pop
out yeah well some of those [ __ ]
alright so channel the ghost of Dennis
Rader even though that [ __ ] still
alive I don't understand how it happens
he's escaping prison through astral
projection and I'm his [ __ ] vessel
you know what's funny is that we were at
our monthly golf night here in Orlando
memento mori which you know check it out
if you're ever in the Orlando area on
the third Monday of the month and they
played I don't know if you guys know I
was like that are into like you know EBM
or industrial or anything like that but
there is a song called BTK by George oh
yeah and I don't remember who it's by
offhand but uh so that song came on like
past Monday and I'm just
and I was like look at him going sexual
problems my god and now I know we were
talking about but you know
so this first guy uh known as the
blackout Ripper his actual name was
Gordon Cummins now at the time that his
murder spree occurred he was a serial
killer but also more a spree killer
because his killings happened like
overall like less than a week period it
was kind of like a Jack the Ripper type
situation but not even that you know
stretched out it was just over a couple
of days um yeah so he was 28 years old
at the time the murders occurred
now what ended up happening with him he
was um a fairly good-looking dude um had
a good education came from a decent
family now he did tell people and I
don't think this is they don't know a
huge amount about his family background
but they do know that he came from like
a pretty normal like you know middle
class to upper middle-class family he
did have a tendency to tell people later
on that he was the illegitimate son of
like some you know Baron or something
like that wasn't he in the RAF he was he
okay you ever thinking of the same one
then yeah yeah he he tried to style
himself as a count kind of like yeah so
that's what so that's what like his
buddies they call me an account or the
Duke or something but yeah this is this
is typical of discourse tension this
kind of guy you know I mean we're there
there there's nothing to them yeah so
they're very insecure and they try to
puff himself up into something that
they're not and then they use this image
to go out and [ __ ]
rape and kill women yeah you know and
this one mutilated them also yeah hence
Ripper
he's a [ __ ] well yeah that should go
would have a thing they're almost always
pathological liars - I'm sure we're
gonna get into that probably he's
probably a [ __ ] heavy liar right um
yeah I guess they didn't really know
like I said they don't know a great deal
about him because this happened in the
1940s it's not like nowadays where they
weren't profiling that we're yeah they
weren't profiling and it's like there
wasn't like 40 million
you know media things about him and this
woman like I said it happened over a
very brief period of time over a brief
period time he killed for women and then
you know only a few days after that he
got caught um tell you he was a
pathological liar
and just yeah I'd his ass off yeah I'm
sure sure but yeah so uh he was
originally from a place called New
Year's WIC I guess that's how you
pronounce it near York he was married he
married a the Secretary of a theater
producer I believe her name was
Geraldine they got married in 1936 she
was apparently super into him I don't
know she ever reported like any abusive
behavior he didn't have any history of
violence any kind of history of any
criminal record of any kind nothing like
that so in a way like I said that's
again what I would I find a little weird
so World War two starts in 1939 and he
enlisted in the RAF in September of that
year
like I said his buddies in the RAF
called him to count or the Duke because
he told people that he was that his dad
he was like the bastard son of like some
[ __ ] laying there Gentry or whatever
even though they don't know if that's
the case it pray it very well could be
but you know they don't really have any
way of proving them now landed gentry
yeah that might mean something in Europe
and landed gentry doesn't mean [ __ ] here
okay
Mississippi there's a lot of people that
have a whole [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] land
and their daughters are twerking on the
back of a mud truck you know right and
they're off their [ __ ] wrestling
alligators and yeah they probably own
the acre that their mobile home is yeah
they got a mobile phone on it and 20
acres and [ __ ] well it depending on
where you are I mean land is pretty
cheap yeah my mom and my stepdad and my
dad would be the land of Chantry he's
got [ __ ] hunting rights on all kinds
of land of hunting more land
that's a damn medieval King had needs
out there [ __ ] hunting deer and [ __ ]
you know and if you could call my dad
landed gentry I'd start laughing you
should you should go around telling
people get on my land
[Laughter]
like you said it was just like the old
days is like when the king is like you
could if you killed the king's dear man
oh my my that's my dear yeah that does
it that's exactly what it's testing my
dad talks like by the way if you hear
like sound in the background that's one
of our very famous song Central Florida
summer storms yeah cuz we're recording
this like an afternoon yeah
like late afternoon yeah it's kind of
like crawl we saw this movie called
Chrono Cross and I'm like I can play see
yeah Florida Florida where it floods and
attacks and the [ __ ] all attacked by
a whole bunch of alligators yeah there
was a funny movie where they looking but
the tone was kind of off I thought it
was liked it I'm like yeah I liked it I
can see what you're saying though it's
like maybe they should have got a little
more like sci-fi move like you know
Crockett tarantulas my dad was seriously
I'd like to see it when I was drunk it'd
be fun well yeah we can do that I'm sure
it'll be on that flex pretty soon you
know what's weird about like Florida
though it's like I'm you know I'm I was
born in Florida and I've seen out I see
alligators all the time but it's like
you know I'm still terrified of them cuz
you know they could eat me and out
really I'm kind of scared of anything
that could eat me like a normal person
should be but I have seen them like just
in normal situations like I've been like
driving down like the [ __ ] highway
like I was driving down 1792 one time
and I saw an alligator just like booking
it like a cross just like running like
it almost got hit by a car because the
car was like oh alligator yeah and I've
heard that like I've never been to the
Everglades but I've heard of people you
know tourists that go to the Everglades
and they're like you know if you go to
like Alligator Alley which is like the
road that goes all the way across the
state like through that through the
Everglades it's like you walk through
this hiking path and there's alligators
just sitting there and be just like
stepping over them because what else are
you gonna do we got a lot we got British
subscribers man I'd like Africa where we
got British subscribers that say stuff
and I got a [ __ ] back them up and say
well you know a lot of the stories that
I tell a lot of things that I say come
from an American a Southerners
perspective you know I'm talking about
we got [ __ ] dinosaurs here this is
Dagobah pretty much this is Dagobert
like I said like on even the path that
we that goes runs behind our house and
the Sanford will kind of trail that we
walk on there is like a little bitty
it's not really a swamp it's more like a
retention pond that you walk and there's
like a little overlook and stuff I've
never seen an alligator and they
but I hear it yeah because they have a
very distinctive wall particularly the
mother when she by calling her babies
and so I'm not a predator yes so we like
walk through there sometimes I'm like oh
there's mama she's calling the babies
and I always look but I can't see her
cuz she's hiding a really good cuz
there's like a lot of reads and shows
read what my work and he's civilized in
these civilized areas up north and
Yankee villain over there new UK that
this doesn't really work here it's a
it's a different reality on the ground
well like I said very different reality
on the ground the south is its own
special zone animal and I mean special
in both the positive and the negative
connotation Florida man all more reason
is Lorna man is a meme for recent normal
logic and reason backfire here okay
everything is counterintuitive I mean a
guy ate someone's face yeah chrissake
it's like you know yeah any [ __ ] up
thing that happens right it's it
happened here under okay if you were to
compare this area between something in
the u EU or the UK this is a lawless
tribal region compared to all that kind
of stuff I mean [ __ ] happens I mean not
we're like where we live it's not that
bad no it's beautiful beautiful here
yeah but it's just it's not operating
under the same law operating system is
civilize the world yeah okay look what's
happening here in I'm gonna tell you
this what's happening here in this area
would be totally unacceptable in Boston
I lived in Boston for six years this
[ __ ] just wouldn't fly it's flying here
flying just [ __ ] I mean it's you know
it's not it's not as bad as the hills
have eyes
yeah I've been to some places of floor
in Florida where yeah I thought about
that movie and thought that could happen
do United States is not one country it's
more like 50 countries in four different
regions they're all just watching the
same they have the same internet they
have the same kind of television but
reality on the ground is not saying no
because the people right keeps this [ __ ]
we have real diversity here real
diversity yeah alright so going back to
World War two and like I said you know
people that didn't grow up in the UK or
didn't grow up in Europe at the time of
the early parts of World War two because
obviously the u.s. didn't get into it
until that later on but from the
beginning of World War two obviously
particularly in London they had
blackouts to keep from you know the
Germans from bombing the cities so what
they would do is they would keep all the
street lights out they like painted all
the windows black or like had heavy
curtains over them and stuff like that
so that at night you couldn't see the
lights and you would get like heavy
fines you would get arrested like if you
had your lights on in your windows or
anything like if anybody could see like
where the cities were on [ __ ] like that
so yeah so you could get like in big
trouble you for having lights on so
there was a lot of [ __ ] going on at the
time too and I think this happens you
know pretty much everywhere like during
wartime especially something that's like
apocalyptic is World War two was where
you know everyone is kind of like taking
shelter and [ __ ] you know tube
stations and like cellars and all this
other kind of [ __ ] but also people have
gotten to a point where they feel like
well I could die tomorrow so I think
people almost have like a bucket kind of
mentality so you know obviously
prostitution goes way way up like
drinking goes way up partying goes way
up which you wouldn't think but you know
people were like crowding dance halls
and all this kind of you know going to
hookers and all this other kind of [ __ ]
because they thought I could be dead
tomorrow I might as new and enjoy
actually just makes a perfect sense or
it does I metal I read a lot of books
about American GIs who most of them do
winter units that I served in like the
first Airborne Division what their
experience were in World War two yeah
and in Germany
okay one of the ones that I read was as
the war started to end German soldiers
started to work alongside American
soldiers as kind of basically police
yeah okay and this American soldier
tells the stories of what this German
soldier who is a sergeant told him you
know while they were doing guard duty
man in the damn checkpoint over a road
and that German loved the war he [ __ ]
loved it he was stationed mostly in
France and had a [ __ ] blast you don't
mean yeah
so many women and just so the nightclubs
were through the [ __ ] roof oh yeah so
war isn't what people think it is I'm an
expert professional soldier you know and
civilians don't really have an idea of
how much fun it is a lot of PTSD guys
and I have PTSD a lot of it involves
with wanting to go back to the army
yeah you know I mean you miss it well
it's a heightened your intensive yeah
yeah so I very much so there's a whole
TED talk about PTSD and about a civilian
reporter who served with guys up on the
mountain and a place called Restrepo in
in in Afghanistan they got attacked the
most okay those guys saw a lot of combat
they have bad PTSD but mostly what they
wanted when it was over is to get back
to their buddies and be back up on the
street but it's a very addictive because
it's like doing meth it's a lot like
yeah it's it's being in a heightened
emotion yeah state all the time and like
when you come back and you have to get
back into a quote-unquote normal life
and I think that's what happened to like
with a lot of people that came back from
World War two
oh this whole war is hell and veterans
of [ __ ] violent that's a world war one
story
those guys were drafted they were sent
to trenches filled with lice they didn't
really do much they just sat out there
they weren't on that right watch that
[ __ ] diamond tree right they shall
not grow like octopus I mean I knew that
[ __ ] but it being it that [ __ ] is
horrifying they weren't on that ragged
edge of kill or be killed and getting
ready to die alright they weren't doing
that Hemingway had it right you give a
bunch of [ __ ] rifles to men and you
send them out to hunt other men they
really kind of lose the taste for
anything else that's really what PTSD is
everybody I know that has it [ __ ]
misses the unit they all want to get
back into action yeah ya know well like
I said you can see why it happened where
and particularly it happened like dudes
coming back from World War two and then
they were supposed to go back into like
this you know normal like suburban night
another word out of life and you can see
why a lot of them like just started
[ __ ] drinking and like they ended up
dying really young mystified Mississippi
and I was a little kid my second cousin
he was a second cousin I I was a little
kid when I last saw him he came back
from the Pacific Island fighting and you
know and he was army and he saw some
[ __ ] heavy action out on those
islands he drank himself to death within
about you know 15 years to come in 20
years coming back yes a lot of a lot of
guys that's all they do is just sit
around think about [ __ ] getting back
on those islands and killing Japs no
that's how they [ __ ] work yeah yeah
yeah he used to wear chaps yeah oh [ __ ]
he would drink an entire fifth of
whiskey
my granddad didn't drink but other than
that it was the same died of cirrhosis
of the liver by the time I was about six
my dad of like emphysema yeah yeah I
remember seeing him and you know and he
was just badass yeah [ __ ] total
badass like I said I think that's kind
of where that whole thing comes from
it's like you know you go there you bond
with all these guys you see these
horrible things you're in this like
emotionally heightened situation like
pretty much 24/7 and everything else are
let down and everything after that is
just like boring yeah I can see that
it's totally understandable yeah you see
it in me yeah I know yeah and like I
said I can understand that I don't yeah
yeah well once you [ __ ] start living
by the sword you actually want to die by
the sword
yeah yeah but it's just because it gets
ingrained into you yeah but you know I
mean I don't know like I don't know if
women really have it the same because
they're you know kind of are we are
hormonal II built for it yeah yeah I
definitely think it manifests itself
differently
you just never know love like that yeah
yeah I mean yeah I got guys on Facebook
I served with and those are my [ __ ]
brothers yeah yeah I mean and we will
die and kill for each other and they're
all in government and law enforcement
agencies now you know I mean and that's
where these guys are coming from
yeah homeland security cops so some of
our sales
you know they're innocent but they're
just mentally that's not where they are
mentally they're back in Korea with me
yeah or you know gulfs go you know it
over in the Gulf you know but yes
there's a lot of you guys out there
contacted me on Facebook in private I
know the deal yeah so in a way like
coming at it from that context it
actually kind of surprises me that there
wasn't more of this kind of [ __ ] going
on right like people like taking
advantage I mean yeah there was like
prostitution was a huge spike that was a
kind of drinking and all that other like
general debauchery um probably murder to
crime and you know I think burglaries
and [ __ ] like that went up so there was
like some of that but I feel like this
guy maybe was like the main you know
serial killer type to come out of this
that was in this particular context or
took advantage of this particular
context so like I said it's you know man
the [ __ ] this storm is bad out there
alligators gonna come through the
[ __ ] window and a big old [ __ ]
wave of water I'll have to put him in
the shower
but yes hopefully the power doesn't go
out yeah we really lose power we're
gonna die actually if it starts lighting
about an hour I think the computer and
the camera will still keep on going
isn't it won't start running off your
battery yeah but I'll probably have to
stop like we'll stop who's continued
show later yeah all right so as I said
you know so blackouts and everything
like that so into this you know sort of
environment comes Gordon Cummins like I
said he's about 28 years old at this
time he was in the RAF now in early whoa
yeah he's up it did he lose it I don't
know did we know it's still on earth
okay we're back yeah we got blown out of
course this is day go by like we were
talking about before and man that the
storm was [ __ ] bad sorry much every
afternoon is Laura yeah so yeah during
the summer so what we did was we went
and saved what we did so we didn't lose
it yeah it kind of waiting it was strike
oh [ __ ]
that's like I'll be really sad if like
Michael [ __ ] computer blows out what
I thought I thought I thought a big wave
of water carrying alligators as
[ __ ] it's not flushing through like that
be agree it's a show it's only July man
it's like it's not even the height of
hurricanes happy a great show [ __ ]
alligator washed in here man yeah it's
all around the world for the people
alligator
Tom wrestles a lot a buddy who's
fighting alligators for living actually
have you ever seen that picture that one
guy at that I don't think it was in
Florida well maybe it was but it was
that one guy that got because it was
like a photo that went around it was
like a viral photo yeah and it was like
an alligator with like a man's hand like
sticking out of you and a lot of people
thought it was photoshopped and so they
for know who was real it was like a guy
he was like a handler and Donald's got
pictures of him fighting alligators that
guy that used to be the bartender and I
bar he's dealing dealing with a whole
nest of alligators for a limo that's
right yeah yeah I forgot all about yeah
the whole alligator show yeah
he's badass bartender or not bartender a
bouncer to I wouldn't [ __ ] with
alligators yeah you know this seriously
though it's like as long as you keep cuz
they they have a hard time like opening
their mouths yeah you can hold it shut
with one hand now once it's open and
we're just man can't get out and you're
in trouble cuz they'll just clamp it and
break your limbs or gotta force bitin
but they don't have but they can't open
it yeah just protip so it once coming at
you in his mouth close just [ __ ] grab
his [ __ ] jaws and hold the shut also
I feel like a lot of people and even
people that have grown up in Florida I
hear them talking about this but there
was like oh you know you can outrun an
alligator on land no no you yeah you
cannot know you can they're very fast
fast fast for a short burst yeah I'm
about you know 15 20 meters they and
they can jump out of the water yeah
their whole entire body length yeah so
if you're just hanging out the bargain
overlooking alligator they can jump out
and get you and that tail can [ __ ] you
up
yeah the tail is very big and very heavy
and if it swings it at you ARBs okay
that really bones
Wow so like I said don't [ __ ] with
alligators you guys that's that's no
joke yeah and bag to bag the store what
we doing that we're talking about The
Blackout Ripper okay
and now like I said before we had our
little power outage incident we were
talking about ironically well it's not
ironic it was just like kind of that's
actually the opposite of ironic it was
actually significantly we were talking
about the blackout in London and then
our kind of power went out because well
it's starting to kind of brown out yeah
anything else and we we lost internet
connection so we thought we were gonna
lose power we had to kind of jump out of
the show for a little bit make save just
in case just in case
that's about what 15 minutes ago yeah
yeah storms cause yeah we just waited
for the storm to blow over a little you
a bigger tropical storms I mean it just
pours down buckets for only a few
minutes and might hear some thunder in
the background but the worst of it seems
to be the lightning striking right there
in the back of the house yeah so we
decided we should stop but yeah so we
were talking about the blackouts in
London to kind of the whole atmosphere
going on around London at the time you
know with all the prostitutes and
whatnot so into this kind of seething
cauldron of uncertainty let's call it
that is this early February of 1942
now here's Gordon come into like I said
at the time is 28 years old and he was
married like I said he had a wife who
was apparently happy with him never
complained about him as far as I know he
goes on Saturday February 8th he goes to
it's funny because some of the sorcerer
he hears to visit his wife I'm like he's
visiting her I don't they live together
or maybe this I don't know it's like he
was in the army right yeah oh that's
true ok so he goes to visit his wife for
the sole purpose of hey can I borrow
some money cuz I'm gonna go out on the
town right yeah let's go bang some
hookers she's like here have some money
I don't know whatever whatever so you
know what I mean I'm doing some R&R I'm
not sure how it works in there so she
gave some money and he goes out on the
town although like I said I probably
shouldn't laugh cuz he's going out to
[ __ ] murder people and that's like
[ __ ] not funny so he goes out into
London's West End to have a good time
that turns out that his good time
apparently entailed killing somebody
yeah the following morning the morning
of February 9th they found the body of
40 year old Evelyn Hamilton she was
found in an air-raid shelter near
arch now at first they thought that it
was just like a robbery gone wrong
because she had to had a handbag and I
had about 80 pounds in it and it was
missing right she had been strangled um
her clothes were kind of like messed up
but she hadn't been sexually assaulted
and she hadn't been mutilated either now
they weren't really sure if she'd been
actually killed in the air-raid shelter
or if she'd been like killed in the
street and the he dragged her down there
and left her down there to like to hide
the body or whatever so police come on
the scene they think it's a robbery gone
wrong um pretty much the only thing like
I said this is the early 1940s they
didn't have like a bunch of forensic
science and all that kind of [ __ ] but
they did determine that the killer was
left-handed which is kind of good cuz
you know if not a lot of people are
left-handed now only a couple of days
later actually this was only like the
next day because it was Monday 10th of
February they found another dead woman
this was a 35 year old woman named
Evelyn Oatley now she was found dead in
her flat which was in Soho now she had
actually know a lot of women did this
during wartime turned to prostitution
even married women and stuff like that
is just to make extra money and because
ice the market was out there so you know
what are you gonna do he tried
everything was rationed and everything
was shitty so I guess a lot of figures
like might as well um she actually when
she was prostituting she went under the
name Nita ward now she had also what
were you gonna say and I say well I
don't think really think that was a
thing in the UK was it yes it very much
was a thing wasn't he illegal though was
it no it really a prostitution was not
illegal until the 1950s I believe maybe
like our British listeners kind of
pretty sure it was the 50s um yeah but
it was actually made illegal at the time
street prostitution was not illegal yes
they're saying that it wasn't it wasn't
really a thing I mean they did it but I
mean that it wasn't a criminal thing
right they just did it was a thing in
that it happened right yeah
yes street prostitution was actually as
far as I know and like I said correct me
if I'm wrong but I think that street
prostitution was still legal in the 40s
it wasn't made illegal until the
nineteen fifty and in the United States
was kind of spotty certain states
tolerated and in other states didn't and
yeah everything kind of depends on so
even now it's like you know the criminal
penalties for it or harsher some places
than others some places it's legal like
some places in Nevada but only if you go
to particular places it's nothing they
get around it now because they don't
charge you for the sex they just charge
you for time and well that's what all
the ads now like escort services and
massage parlors and stuff it's like yeah
there's work arounds you know what I
mean
I mean street prostitution as far as I
know is technically illegal everywhere
but it just depends where you are like
well yes some cities it just was never
enforced yeah they just yes look at some
cities they don't enforce it it just
depends so Evelyn Utley was also
strangled now like I said she was found
in her apartment so apparently Gordon
Cummins had paid her for her services
and they'd gone back to her flat and he
and he had killed her she had been
strangled however after she was dead he
also uh cut her throat she was found
naked she had been mutilated most
sources say sexually mutilated with a
can opener which they also found at the
scene that had blood all over it and
fingerprints yeah so when they examined
that they found the fingerprints and the
way that the crime was committed the way
the throat was slit and stuff like that
they determined again the killer was
left-handed so yeah how the hell do you
what do you do with the can opener get
back this I said sexually mutilated with
a can opener
yeah they must be talking about I don't
know like a wrench yeah I have a picture
yeah I have a picture of it that's on
one yeah it's like it's like a long
handle and like a curved like a big huge
curved blade like that okay like a
littler almost like a little hammer and
occurrence so whenever you can hurt
somebody with you it's basically like a
knife like a little curved blades on it
yeah that's the Monica that I have a
picture of the actual ones back in
Brazil my maid could open a [ __ ]
because we had a maid
don't I live back in Brazil as a kids
into this yeah your money but of course
my somebody back me who grew up in a
[ __ ] trailer park yeah
hey prom king well you know I lived in a
lot of different places when I was a kid
I was moving between two parents you
know I mean [ __ ] my mother and father
with a divorce my mother remarried to a
rich guy Linda blue in Brazil so it's
you know between Mississippi Brazil in
California depending on what time it was
not my maker bring out a serrated steak
knife just the kind that a person
[ __ ] opens you know cuts a steak with
here in the you take that steak knife
and open a can in about ten seconds but
that snake dies it was amazing I can do
it that's pretty amazing I can show you
I wasn't as good as she was that's how
she grew up name is Sita grew up in the
favellas sambal oh yeah I feel table
Eleazar [ __ ] yeah jumping she could
sit like if I try to do that I'd
probably just end up slash she's badass
cuz I'm super clumsy she ended up dying
later his damn brain tumor how old was
she young she died about thirty two of a
brain tumor my uncle did too yes 32
years old he also died never brain to
Eddie okay yeah it hit her and you
couldn't help her yeah I mean that's
hard we didn't have the mind to help her
yeah I'm just tired of branches she's
slowly went insane then died yikes
yeah that's horrifying yeah so yeah so
again can opener so she was mutilated
with a can opener
um police quickly also determined that
this killer was also left-handed so they
imagine that it was probably the same
guy even though the first victim was not
mutilated but like I said this almost
seems like an escalation very much like
a Jack the Ripper type of thing going on
because he made Jack the Ripper's early
victims there was some mutilation but
not as much and then like the last one
was like he just cut her apart and like
all her guts were everywhere so that's
kind of what happened in this situation
also now the next day like I said this
was only this was less than a week that
should happen while the [ __ ] blackout
and all the air raids and [ __ ] were
going on so the next day Tuesday
February 11th now there was another
woman who had also been working as a
prostitute her name was Margaret Lowe
she was also known as pearl her age is
usually given as 40 to 43 somewhere
around there she was also murdered in
her own flat which was in goss field
street
she had been strangled with a silk
stocking of hers mutilated probably
sexually mutilated although like I said
a lot of papers at the time wouldn't say
stuff like that they wouldn't even say
raped they would just say like
criminally yeah mashed yeah or something
like that it's like they wouldn't even
say it
yeah it's like people did it but they
wouldn't talk about I think maybe that
might be some of the reason why some
people have this like kind of glowing a
more positive view about how good the
past yeah just because it's like this
[ __ ] happened it's like they didn't talk
about it though like even in the
newspaper reports they would use like
all these euphemisms yes because they
didn't want to say they want to be
disrespectful yeah they don't want to
like say exactly what it they want to be
obscene to these people I mean you know
that was the same thing in the South
going way back you know I mean they just
wouldn't say exactly what happened which
is dumb cuz you're being clever being
Christian about it they're being Baptist
about it
that's what [ __ ] me up there it's like
oh well we can I wish we can do that
kind of stuff but we can't call it that
we can't talk about it yeah that's super
[ __ ] up
yeah we don't minimize it in certain
ways I think it helped though because it
stopped things from spreading yeah
people always talking about school
shootings and mass murders and schools
and [ __ ] nowadays that was happening it
was happening back then actually there
were more of them back then yeah it's
just if they didn't talk about them yeah
and I think it it stopped
kids from trying to emulate that well if
you don't hear about it maybe don't hear
it dummy
you know think about that idea and you
wouldn't think of the FBI I told them
you know the news media says it probably
not a good a good idea to talk about
this cuz you'll just encourage more of
it they were right but and the modern
era it's impossible to control them like
I said I think that cats are doors open
versus have run out whatever old timey
farm metaphor you want to use right it's
probably too late to do mass shootings
go all the way back to the 1800s
well yeah nothing new like I said I feel
like I said I think there were more of
them back in the old days but you didn't
hear about it as much and like I said
news it was an Internet like immediately
international it was all local so in
some ways like it seems like it happens
more now
yeah but it's just because you're
hearing about is less well because
you're
during about one that might have
happened in another country whereas like
before you wouldn't have heard about it
because she didn't we were to look at
the United States in the population
level and then the amount of guns in
here you're I'm amazed that it is as low
as it is it's it's very very rare you
have a lot of Fortis to hold they have
guns there must be deadly no not really
it's really not that it's not really I
mean there's places that I wouldn't go
to that I myself and the other thing
that's true but it talked about it on
the Internet where the crime happens in
these cities it actually goes along
certain borders of the streets yeah you
can say it's this particular
neighborhood yeah that's doing it all
and I'm not saying that like every now
and cuz like I said I've written about
lots and lots of cases where the [ __ ]
was like nothing like this had ever
happened your port is totally random so
nothing it doesn't happen it does it
does happen Ram is very like I'm not
saying like you shouldn't worry about it
cuz yeah it could happen to you but the
likelihood is very low Oh Mary Bennet
we've been around major shootings the
[ __ ] damn pulse nightclub shooting
happened just right the street we were
there that night you're like we were
only like a block we were like a walkway
that happened but that was sucking
religion that was behind that a lot of
this [ __ ] is either religion and drugs
95 percent of all these [ __ ]
shootings here in the United States
drugs yeah it's drug war yeah if you
actually look at who's being shot good
riddance cuz it's just two groups of bad
guys shooting each other most of the
time they're bad on both sides yeah oh
yeah there's a Darwin Awards really a
lot of it is Darwinism well like I said
a lot of it is criminal on criminal on
criminal you know but to me that's a
Darwin Award so yeah so this woman gets
murdered um like I said she got
strangled with a silk stocking she was
mutilated with a razor blade and a knife
and also just to be extra [ __ ] II he
took a candlestick and stuffed it up her
vagina her couch yeah
[ __ ] he's a dick yeah just minor
Iong to [ __ ] this man is
to disgrace a woman postmortem yeah she
is pretty much most of the stuff because
all of the most strangled yeah but all
of the mutilations like to chop all the
chopping up and stuff he did that was
postmortem Sam is a little similar to
Jack the Ripper but cut that man's head
off I was cut that man now interestingly
the pathologists at working on his case
who was Bernard Spilsbury who I guess he
was like a really famous like
pathologist at the time or he works on a
lot of cases because on a lot of cases
that I wrote about in my book like
especially like the one where like all
the body parts were found in the trunk
like I think it happened in Brighton he
was like the pathologist on that one too
because I was like I was listening to a
podcast about this Emily oh I know that
guy I can print about that guy before he
worked on a bunch of those [ __ ] up
cases back then how that poor guy I
don't know how he slept at night but
yeah heaps all kind of [ __ ] hmm so yeah
so he saw the mutilations and I you know
I haven't seen photographs or anything
it's like just the vague description is
bad enough but he concluded that the
murder was likely a quote-unquote savage
sexual maniac like yeah yeah
understatement of the century
okay so yeah and at this point they were
pretty sure they weren't sure about the
first one you know at this stage but the
second - they were like for sure that's
the same person plus they have only
happened like within a day of each other
now the next day after that so like this
said this guy is not wasting any time
it's like you know there's a blackout
it's a week I'm just gonna go out he's
got a job to do
I guess it lets him like that and like I
said he's like nobody had any [ __ ]
inkling of this [ __ ] beforehand
I mean he was 28 years old he wasn't
super I mean that's and yeah it was on
brave or he's on pass
I don't really know honestly he's trying
to get it all in before he has to go
back to go back to the army it's like
what this is on your bucket list is that
like something you want what the [ __ ]
man it's like our long past and he's
only got a limited amount of time see oh
I got a kill I gotta go back yes what is
what the [ __ ] man I don't get it
whatever you did yeah so the next day
which was Wednesday February 12th 1942
there was another one her name was Doris
and I'm not sure how her last name is
pronounced I think is jus na or jus
Annette um different sources have given
different ages some say she was 40 some
say she was
thirty two so we'll just say whatever
there I know it is like but they said
she also went by the name Doris Robson I
don't know if she was a prostitute or
she just went by another neighbor that
was her maiden name or whatever um she
got murdered in her ground floor flat in
the Paddington district now she was
married her husband lived there as well
he was a hotel manager
so I guess she was kind of like doing
the prostitution thing on the side of
her husband probably knew about it I
think a lot of dudes at the time did so
she would go to Leicester Square and she
would pick up servicemen there like for
money or whatever so same kind of thing
she'd been strangled with a scarf and
she was also sexually mutilated now the
day after that like I said this dude is
like not this is like every [ __ ] day
bam-bam-bam he's got a very short
refractory period I guess he can get it
up it goes down he's gotta get it back
up again he's yeah he's a dick just like
out of nowhere this is just like a huge
crazy
I mean like I said you know it's not
because the media at the time was not as
[ __ ] saturated especially with all
this crime kind of stuff there's no tell
like this guy might have done so a bunch
of [ __ ] like before this and got away
with it cuz nobody suspected him but I
mean it he didn't have any criminal
record or anything like probably what
happened is he killed that first one so
you figured oh they're gonna catch me I
don't I don't [ __ ] have long so I may
as well do a whole bunch of other ones
before they actually catch up to me it
does seem like probably what he's doing
it's probably like in a panic yeah it's
like oh well I got limited time I bet
yeah they're gonna get me I better
[ __ ] know what kind of quota I gotta
[ __ ] I gotta get some more in before
they catch out to me that's what he's
doing
holy [ __ ] yeah so the next day he's
probably very paranoid he's probably
[ __ ] thinking that they're just one
step behind him well they were like I
said they come yes so the next day which
was Thursday there was a woman named
mrs. Greta Haywood and she was picked up
by Gordon Cummins
at a bar now he asked her to go for a
drink and she said okay but then he
started making like a lot of like overt
sexual advances and she said no and she
like was kind of scared of him so she
ran off and you know the streets it's
London it's everything's dark like all
the windows
blacked out on everything and there's no
streetlights so she runs off now he runs
after her and catches up with her and he
catches her in at st. Alban street he
forces her into a doorway like of a
store or something and he like grabs her
by the throat and starts to strangle her
now she actually collapsed she got she
went unconscious but then like a
delivery guy like came around the corner
like going on his rounds or whatever and
I guess like Gordon saw him and he was
like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna get caught so he
just like took off so she lived now
interestingly though at the scene like a
[ __ ] dumbass this blackout Ripper
left his gas but some sources say his
gas mask or the box that his gas mask
was in and it had his name rank and
serial number on it so not the sharpest
no knife dumbass in the drawer he wasn't
thinking ahead clearly this is all
impulse yeah this like I said it's
definitely an impulse yeah disorganized
killer and salad he wasn't stalking
anybody he was just whoever was around
hey there's a prostitute
I'm wasn't planning on killing somebody
sorry because I'm gonna get this one
yeah he's doing yeah so because Gordon
Cummins like a dumbass as I said left
his [ __ ] gas mask and/or the box at
the gas mask came in that had his name
and [ __ ] on it so the police knew where
to go looking for him now before they
even had a chance to do that like this
was only like less than a day later the
[ __ ] tries to attack another one
yeah now this was another prostitute her
name was Katherine Mulcahy also called
Kathleen King she was also attacked in
her apartment which was near Paddington
rail station now apparently he gave her
five pounds for her services which is I
guess what it was going for back then
she blew it but yes but I guess like
once he started getting violent she
wasn't having it and I guess she liked
she still had her boots on because it
was February it was cold outside so I
you know her plat didn't have any heat
or whatever so she still had her boots
on he started getting like that way and
she [ __ ] started kicking his ass
right and he threw her another five
pound note and ran so I was like that
was just very very funny to me I'm like
man you go girl it sounds like a man of
course like I said before running out of
time yeah get caught so he's just gonna
come in as many crimes as you can till I
catch up with him yeah like I said I'm
not talking about a [ __ ] criminal
mastermind here clearly no neither of
these guys were now heading down one
crime and then just vanished and stopped
well yeah they never would have content
Ross you know like I said in
particularly in the 30s and the 40s in
the wrong time period particularly there
was a lot of these kind of like weird
one-off yeah crimes it's like hey I
killed a girl and cut her up and left
her in a trunk somewhere and nobody ever
caught them never got did that you could
have just done it once and then backed
off for four or five months and let the
[ __ ] cops you know let them get their
guard down they could have done it again
yeah they may have not even realized
that was the same guy well you shan't
even Jack the Ripper like spaced the
[ __ ] out yeah this guy was just like
every day it's like hey I'm gonna go
kill another one I don't know what you
were thinking George but anything just
pours the pressure on the cops to find
the guy but like I said they found him
pretty much man like I said they were
lucky too because this guy was kind of
in it but also okay so they um had the
[ __ ] with his name on it so obviously
they went to the thing and they were
like hey Gordon Cummins and he's like oh
well no because I have an alibi cuz look
you know when you're in the RAF or
whatever every time you go out on leave
you have to like sign in and out right
so he's like look I signed back in
before midnight like every night that
those women were killed okay which at
first you would think was like that's a
pretty rock-solid alibi right it's like
you know he signed in he was here
everybody saw him blah blah blah but
then as the police investigated they
discovered that it was pretty common
practice for a lot of the guys in the
little thing there to just like sign
each other in and out because people
like hey can you just like sign in for
me cuz I don't wanna get in trouble I'm
gonna do this on the other so they were
always like signing each other in write
so it turned out that on one particular
night in question you know when one of
the women was killed that after he had
signed in or had somebody
Simon then somebody saw him and another
guy leaving like like sneaking out a
[ __ ] fire escape later on so he was
obviously like either having someone
else sign him back in or signing it and
then sneaking back out so that's what
that what was going on there so finally
they're like all right whatever
[ __ ] so they caught him and
they searched him and they found a in
the pocket of his shirt or his jacket or
whatever they found a cigarette case
belonging to one of his victims he oh
they also found a fountain pen which
belonged to one of his other victims and
when they took fingerprints it matched
fingerprints that they found in two of
the flats like two of the murder scenes
his fingerprints also matched the bloody
fingerprints that were found on the can
opener that was found to mutilate one of
the that was had been used to mutilate
one of the victims also and as I said
this guy you know no criminal history
nothing of any like not even petty
crimes because usually this type of
stuff you know start out as like petty
criminals but he did as far as I know
yeah I guess so yeah but like I said so
you know he did these crimes like in the
early part of February February 16th
he was arrested so you know as they
found his fingerprints at three of the
crime scenes and also had the gas mask
mask with his name on it and all that
other kind of crap so clearly they put
him on [ __ ] trial in April of that
year now they only put him on trial for
one murder of that of Evelyn Oatley
because they figured that if he got
acquitted of that then they could
immediately like do another one you know
what I mean because they said if we do
all of them and it doesn't go through
then he might go free so I want to make
sure let's do one at a time just in case
right but even though it was only one
crime I believe that the jury only took
about half an hour and they were like
yeah hang that [ __ ] right yeah
so uh yeah they did they sentenced him
to death by hanging and like I said he
had done the murders in February they
arrested in February 16th he was put on
trial on April 27th and on the 25th of
June they hanged his ass so good he
seems worth prison during an air raid
so what kind of guy are we talking about
what did he say about all this
not a lot actually it really didn't seem
like he had much of an excuse it didn't
really seem like who knows and like I
said he did like mutilations and [ __ ] it
was he I mean when he looked like what
was the deal with this guy just a normal
looking dude he was a normal looking
dude nobody knows much about it
nah there wasn't like a lot about his
you know younger life or anything like
that it's just he seemed like a regular
dude he was married what'd he say I mean
what was his explanation did he even
give an explanation I don't think you
did well I had him kill a [ __ ] I mean
what'd he say let me say nothing not as
far as I know not that I could find
damn so he just seemed like this type of
dude now from what I remember for the
movies that I saw he was just kind of
like a fake snob you know yeah he did
kind of have this putting on airs type
of oh yeah yeah now to our British
listeners [ __ ] the worst thing you
could ever call a [ __ ] United
States is a [ __ ] snotty well I don't
know I could think of a lot it's not
like it's not you know I mean they're
not there you slap us you slap us not
around but now he's just kind of a
[ __ ] dude that thought he was
something but there really wasn't much
to him and he was kind of a yeah I
remember he wasn't a bad-looking guy no
he was just like I said he was a totally
normal and looking dude he was trying to
he thought it was Errol Flynn running
around [ __ ] killing [ __ ] or
something like I said maybe he just
thought in all this war time she's like
I'm just I'm gonna be Jack the Ripper he
decided was gonna cosplay as Jack the
Ripper yeah that was like like I said
that was like his life goal I don't know
dude I guarantee you do as a loser who's
a past pathological liar
our lawyer he felt that he didn't
measure up to his own expectations and
this is this is how he was gonna
compensate in some way I don't want to
pecker check this [ __ ] but I
guarantee his leg thanks Mitch I've been
guarantee he was a little dick
[ __ ] well like I said aren't
they all and I hate not a little dick my
[ __ ] I'm not some little dick
[ __ ] said cool dudes it's just
that sometimes a little dick
[ __ ] wants to you know I mean
well well himself into something that he
isn't combined with
caller compensation trying to
overcompensate in ways that are not
healthy yeah if you're a little dick
[ __ ] you better be charming yeah
some other atrophy become rich that will
make you more attractive yeah yeah like
you know make money be funny you know
charming things you know let me just
have something else to offer plenty
successful little dick [ __ ] out
there yeah of course they're out there
dick size is really not I think men
think it's more important than women it
is and we know one of them we know one
of them but he he compensated by coming
very physically fit and I don't think it
actually just really worked so you're
just like shooting your hole he was
trying
he was defeating himself over it make
him into something that it wasn't like
it's alright I feel like dudes have like
a real problem with this because I like
they they have like a real sense of
inadequacy God more important and really
important I mean to women to most women
anyway most well I'm gonna name a dude's
name but he's a good-looking guy is an
older guy he's extremely physically fit
and he's loved thick [ __ ] and he
won't I can't get over it
so anytime something doesn't go right
with some girl he blames it on that yeah
and that's not what it is dude it's just
that you're a downer well and you can't
get over the [ __ ] I think it this kind
of happens a lot in you know you're kind
of in cell type communities and stuff
like that because I feel like dudes they
have a thing where they never want to
like they're not introspective like
these type of dudes they don't want to
like look at themselves go what can I do
to be better you know maybe I'm a jerk
maybe I can run strongly maybe this that
they claim something else on like I feel
like and this is a very generalized
statement so please don't like take this
as like Oh men do this but women do that
but in a general way women tend to
internalize their problems like they
feel like if something goes wrong it's
my fault so we're much more
introspective in that way what did I do
wrong
whereas dudes will blame someone else
yeah you know what I mean in general no
not everybody's like that but in in
general that that's I've found that
that's the case there little dink
[ __ ] out there
shit-ton of women that's what I mean
it's like big dick [ __ ] out
there that couldn't touch up yeah I mean
just like it's it's just like anything
else and like I feel like like I said
there's a lot of this in the Intel
committee oh you have to have this
perfect bone structure you have to have
money you have something like that it's
like that's really not the case it's
rich women are actually a lot more
forgiving I mean most women are it's
like yeah there's some certain like you
know [ __ ] shallow women just like
there's [ __ ] shallow men it's like you
know what I mean it's like but those
people you don't want to hang out with
them anyway it's like most people are
very and most women in particular very
forgiving if you have something to offer
like I said might be funny be charming
because you think you should it be
something if you were to actually look
at it by the book I'm too short but I've
never had a problem with I never he
never has never and because he's not
make an issue of it and some of these
women that I went out with in my past
were six-footers big old tall women yeah
and in my experience being a shorter guy
I'm only five six the taller a woman was
the easier it was to get with that
because tall women have a heart too they
have a long time and in fact I think she
might have a worse time than she I think
so if she was tall and good-looking I
was right there yeah no I mean talk it
easy yeah easy
just treat it like a [ __ ] person and
have a good not sure why people yeah and
tell her she's tall and foot tall and
beautiful you know I mean and they just
suck I mean anybody everybody wants to
be appreciated for what they are yeah
everybody wants to be loved for where
they are that's all you have to do you
just have to offer that yeah when I was
when I was in high school when I was
living when I was out in Brazil an
international school there was I went
out with a girl who was big old tall
girl from Sweden she must mean six foot
one six foot two beautiful it was like
having sex with a horse but happy that
she'd been on is she been gone over at
hand that stool get up on a stool
research it
felt like she she pride felt like she
was having sex with Chihuahua
yes [ __ ] was this [ __ ] was magic this
[ __ ] was magic you just gotta make it
you're out there please let me know if
this together you just gotta accept
things for how how they got a hat you
just gotta accept things for how they
are you know the man people are
different
everybody that's the thing people are
different everybody has strengths and
weak weaknesses all you have to do yeah
discover what you're good at is roll
with exercises to throw with that have
fun discover what you're bad at minimize
that the old if you forgot any in cells
out there you know I mean look I'm gonna
taste some the number one way to get up
a woman's skirt is to talk your way up
it and you better be [ __ ] funny if
you're [ __ ] funny and you're cool to
her you like I said just treat her like
a person like the problem I think with a
lot of these type of dudes is they don't
know how to elevate yeah it's like they
just they think everything is the
women's 400 women just want good-looking
our big dick or rich or whatever but I'm
like no it's just because you're an
[ __ ] okay and the fact that you don't
realize that is putting people on yeah
yeah I'll click on over to some of these
insel big towel videos and I'm gonna say
Mick Tao is men going your yarn way a
lot of these guys are not don't look
that side up it's a lot a lot of them
nice guys they're just very misguided
and if you ask me inexperienced and
they're there um stereotype and women
and yeah and we're not a hive mind no
yeah they're stereotype and women and
they're doing this because they don't
know women yeah and the reason why they
don't know women is because they're
approaching it as if they're trying to
climb Mount Everest it doesn't take a
[ __ ] rocket scientist know be
yourself just have [ __ ] fun these are
people problem to a lot of the problem
too is that a lot of their approaches
quote-unquote goal oriented and women
don't like that it's like women don't
like to be able to see right through
that
yeah it's like we're not dumb okay right
like they can
you coming at us like hey I want to [ __ ]
you and it's like that's very right
off-putting my whole life I've been
fighting my whole life I've been very
popular with women I got the pictures to
prove it but I've been very popular
women but it's because it didn't make a
big deal out of it and women it's not
just women you've dated it's you like
you have grants I got yeah you have a
probably equal amount and like I have an
equal amount male-female friends so to
you it's like you have an equal met
because you see you approach people as
you people instead of like man woman
listen let you just listen to them yeah
I can know how to talk be honest and
[ __ ] you know let people know who you
are you know if you're a bad person you
tell me I'm having this problem
it works out yeah it works out I think
the thing like I said don't pretend to
be something over time you know right
because that's something that a lot of
people pick up on it comes up office
creepy yeah um you know just kind of be
yourself and don't don't blame other
people Israel for your misfortunes it's
like there's [ __ ] you have to work on
and look everybody's got weaknesses you
got to work on and don't be don't be
goal-oriented I've been out with [ __ ]
women that look like supermodels and
other ones that were just ugly ducklings
there was I had a good time on either
side because I was looking at him as
people not so much
some of these women that are absolutely
gorgeous they're [ __ ] as people
they're not all that well yeah you know
when you first might score that you're
like oh man this chicks awesome man a
good time that wears off really quick
the way someone looks kind of wears off
you know Jenny saw they had before
before me and you were going out yeah I
was going out with it hi she was a
Disney princess yeah that [ __ ] wore off
[ __ ] quick very quick or five days
this [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy you know me but
yeah and I've told you the same thing
it's like I'm from the female
perspective like and I know this is
weird to say and I don't know if a lot
of people will get this cuz I know dudes
are more visually oriented yeah
I'm not all that visually or even just
are uh yeah it's just in not in the same
way same way um so even if somebody goes
oh hey look at that hot guy over there
look at his butt or whatever it's like I
know this is funny but a lot of hot guys
are dicks well yeah and I've told my
friends this too I'm like I don't know
if he's hot or not because I don't know
him right
I don't have into dicks and I'm going to
tell you almost all a really hot women
are [ __ ] well then there is there is
some treat and I'm not gonna generalize
cuz like I said I've been friends with
some very very super hot girls that were
super super nice oh yeah and there are a
few yeah and I've been friends with like
you know some not so attractive girls
who were also crazy Oh Laura Laura Laura
Laura
Ross no relation to me great looking
ones super [ __ ] good soul to her yeah
yeah I mean but there are other women
that [ __ ] look as good as earlier
[ __ ] garbage and like I said you
that's why I mean that's what I mean you
can't tell and like I said there's
there's no like recipe for like oh
they're good-looking so must be a dick
or they're good-looking so they say
there's no way of knowing and that's why
I said that's why I have this metric
where it's like I can't tell if anyone's
hot or not because I don't know them
until I know you as a person the more I
know you if you're a cool person then
you become more attractive that's how
that works I mean you know cuz I cuz
I've gone out with dudes before to that
we're like you know people might look at
them and be like oh you know they're not
that great looking or they're just
average looking or whatever but they had
something else that was attractive in
general looks kind of wears off that's
what I mean and everybody a lot more to
it everybody gets old
everybody gets you know fat and diseased
and stuff like that it happens to
everyone so that's something that's very
fleeting and you can't base a whole
thing on that well not only that a
person can still be good-looking and you
get sick of them because this is not
there yeah because you're just yeah cuz
if you're not a good person or you don't
have anything in common with them you
could be is you could be a 10 and you're
still gonna drop down to about two and
this is something a lot of these dudes
like you know I I'm in I'm into fitness
I like to [ __ ] work out and [ __ ]
there's a lot of dudes that work out
because they're overcompensating for
other things
and they still can't [ __ ] hook up
with a woman because they haven't
figured that out yeah yeah you know I
mean that women are not very visual but
you're working on something that a lot
of women really aren't that it's gotta
be a mixture of everything yeah it'd be
full spectrum or like I said you have to
at least and I think calm like I think
there's two there's kind of this
misconception where a lot of people say
like oh girls like [ __ ] that's not
the case no um women like bad boys but a
balance right they don't want somebody
that's always like questioning themself
or is down on themselves it's like
nobody wants to hang out with somebody
that's always like down on them yeah I
don't want to go a sliprock you guys I
don't want to hang like that either I
mean it's like like I said you know
women are more forgiving of that kind of
stuff because we can kind of like you
know you know kind of cry into each
other's beer or whatever about you know
problems and that's fine but I'm just
saying nobody wants to be around someone
that's a [ __ ] downer all the time
it's always like oh I suck so much it's
like who the [ __ ] wants to hang out with
us so you know you want somebody that's
like fun or funny Earth's like you know
that you have a good time with her you
feel good when you're with that person
that's that's it it's really as simple
as that
take it take it we're old we're giving
you a yes I have a younger audience you
take this [ __ ] from all the greatest
porn star of all time ron jeremy ron
jeremy talking about women he says the
best-looking women in the world don't
mean [ __ ] if they're not into it
it was mostly and he was mostly into a
woman's vibe you know main [ __ ] as
well I mean yeah very much into people's
vibe into what their vibe was if they
were if they were happy to be there and
they were you know [ __ ] entertain and
it does get to a point to where you
become an old veteran of [ __ ] mastery to
where the [ __ ] visual part is only
just one little aspect of it the rest of
it is it's more of like the vibe well do
you know I mean do you know who I like I
mean you know this probably but one of
the favorite one of my favorite like
female porn performers
yeah is belladonna yeah yeah she's not a
beautiful girl I mean she's a pretty
girl you know she has admitted by the
way yeah she's a she's a cute girl yeah
but the reason I liked her was because
you could tell she was having a really
good time you happy to be there she was
happy to be there yeah you know what
nobody wants to interpersonally women
don't yeah we particularly do not want
to watch porn where it looks like the
woman's like yeah yeah okay you look at
her why it's like you know you can feel
that vibe it's like it's not so fun now
belladonna was [ __ ] happy yeah she
loved that [ __ ] and she had her own
production company she has other toys
and everything like that so that really
comes through and I she was been saving
up for them productions she's like going
on dry like a dragon I gotta make a film
in about five days I'm crap how do we
get for like serial killers to porn this
is the nature of this nature of the
[ __ ] 13 o'clock show this is a show
more than anything else it's a show it's
an educational already is a ringmaster
and some elephants yeah exactly
all right we need to take a break right
now and then when we come back we will
do the second half of the show we're
talking about another [ __ ] just
like this except same time period but on
a different continent but same kind of
deals like taking advantage of wartime
conditions to do this [ __ ] horrible
[ __ ] that they're doing that would be
the brownout strangler Eddie Leon Sookie
so we will talk about him after the
break and we will be back in just a
minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look I got baby cookie a little chew toy
that has mint in it and she loves that
[ __ ] she's like rubbing it all over yeah
oh it's good
get it Pookie get it yeah
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back on the second half
of our show talking about wartime
darkness murderers yeah we're back for
the second half we already just got a
request to do a movie retrospective on
Roadhouse we definitely do it I would
definitely do a retrospective on
rowhouse I want to get that [ __ ] on
blu-ray though you know lepre house it's
so lovable gotta get broad house on
blu-ray and I gotta get Lionheart on
blu-ray with [ __ ] Vonda Lionheart
kickboxer what I get that oh yeah oh
yeah
some of those older classics there make
a lot of though I got a lot of other old
classics so I like you know if I can
Steven Seagal movie wonderful man he's a
[ __ ] wonderful man yeah awesome
well yeah I like that old ship and it
was so cheesy good there's something
kind of sublime about Roadhouse though
because I mean and I'm saying this is
like you know anybody that's a regular
watch of the show you know like a huge
huge Mystery Science Theater dork I've
seen every single episode at least 20
times and mike nelson of mst3k is
famously a huge fan of Roadhouse and
they made so so many like [ __ ]
references to it on the show it was the
very end of the mullet there's just
something so delightful about it it's
it's a bad movie but in a way that's
like like I said it's like a sublime you
know there's there's like this little
gap in between this leg right this is a
shitty movie and this is like a super
awesome movie and then there's like this
little speaking of shitty movies
if you look on Facebook and go Tom
shitty movies Andy's shitty with the 2ds
I have a I have a show there on Facebook
we call I have a Facebook group yeah and
gonna show it's not show but we talk
about this kind of [ __ ] and we laugh
about stuff so people look up on
Facebook Tom shitty movies and if I
accept y'all that's you and you know
what's kind of interesting speaking of
Mystery Science Theater and you wouldn't
think this and this only came this was
only discovered by me today when I was
researching this case that we're talking
about the brownout strangler at Ely
Otsuki there is an mst3k connection here
I'm gonna save that till the end that'll
be a surprise yes I was a surprise to
you and I'm like not [ __ ] with that
out loud by myself but yeah while I was
reading about this case okay a Roadhouse
we're gonna do road do road one do
Roadhouse won't do Lion Heart one do
kickboxer we're gonna do some of the
[ __ ] like marked for death and some
of the old [ __ ] Seagal movies -
that's just [ __ ] hilarious only the
old ones his new ones are like I mean
I'm not saying as old ones aren't
self-important but his new ones are very
self-important the new only has a much
higher opinion of himself than anyone
else on earth even his mother Segal's
newer movies are very generic if you ask
me yeah blow through me like smog and I
hate spunk yeah what [ __ ] is this you
know man it's the older ones were
actually kind of presented as if they
were real movies so so there's some to
him that was I mean he did do some good
ones I'm just gonna tell you there were
couple the under siege movies I liked
him 1 & 2 I liked him I thought they
were hilarious yeah I don't like them
they're not good movies but they're
happening there are what they are yeah
baby John's [ __ ] being over-the-top as
a [ __ ] he's good in everything you
have [ __ ] old what's-his-name [ __ ]
a crazy blond-haired guy from there's a
lot of those oh [ __ ]
was it the guy with the teeth got rid of
teeth was it then be with [ __ ] yeah
Gary Busey
yeah wait was it Gary Busey or Jake
Busey Harry okay
Gary's the dad the dad they both have
two teeth though let me tell you
something Gary Busey act his ass off
when he showed up in your movie you were
gonna get a movie well he's kind of like
well yeah you is kind of like Nicolas
Cage in the bed it was like even if the
movie sucks when you see him you're like
all right we're all right now yeah but
who sees misdialed that [ __ ] in he was
gonna give you a performance that's what
I mean
and Nicolas Cage show set to it's like I
love dudes it's like even in like as
shitty as the movie is it's like hey
will you be in my like nephew's wedding
video and they turn up and they just
like give it their all man yeah a
[ __ ] movie I respect that even if
they chew the scenery
just entertain me man okay but I'm just
each one was [ __ ] a classic I like
[ __ ] classic and it had titties okay
titties a pop-up out of a cake before
you even didn't expect that's the only
theme that I remember from that it was
an entire woman with us on it yeah
you had [ __ ] Segal act to try to act
like a real man even though you run like
a [ __ ] trying to be a Cajun yeah the
only other thing yeah yeah yeah with a
fake Cajun accent I was gonna say
speaking of Gary Busey for the
retrospective we should definitely do
Silver Bullet one of these okay lean do
Silver Bullet yeah another Stephen King
cuz we just did Christine and I kinda
wait a long time
summer bullets good that's like that's
another kind of underrated okay we'll go
look at that like it's not scary or
anything but it was yeah it's
entertaining okay yeah and that was like
published I remember it being published
as like a graphic novel and another one
I want to revisit his Lost Boys I
haven't seen that how do you not like
Lost Boys man I haven't seen him forever
I saw it back in the day
well yeah I thought when it came out I
wanna snuff how dad's aged I wanna see
how it's still good I thought about a
year it's still good I mean I liked it
just as much but maybe that's just gonna
mold other okay on to the next case is
great so now as I said no in the earlier
part of this show we were talking about
[ __ ] Gordon Cummins the so called the
blackout Ripper who for whatever reason
decided hey everyone's like windows are
blacked out all the streetlights are out
so I'm gonna just go cut up a bunch of
women over a week period for whatever
reason now as I said I'm kind of shocked
that this didn't happen more often
however I didn't even know this but it
did happen the only reason I found out
about this guy was because this guy is
linked at the bottom of the Wikipedia
article for the first guy and I was like
brownout strangler it's like who's that
cuz you know at the bottom of Wikipedia
sometimes they're like see also like
this related Brown topic bradda it's
kinda like brown dough I know it's like
something
it's a it's it's like I wish they had
come up with something better like a
better term for that like I see how they
did that it's like it's a blackout cuz
all the lights are out it's a brown axe
only some of the lights are out from
from a more civilized it should have
been like navy blue something are grayed
out why not gray out there just doing
what they gonna do cuz Brown really it's
like okay but yeah so that's the only
reason I knew about this guy even though
as I found out later there was like a
movie made about him and everything like
that so this guy was called the brownout
strangler I'm sorry it's like every time
I say he's gonna cackle like I said but
head over there hey next-gen this is
x-gen humor we're talking about I feel
like a lot of younger people are popular
stranger things is that's like every
single thing oh yeah oh look they're
referencing Fast Times at Ridgemont High
yeah they're Millennials you got you
guys are [ __ ] idealistic we're x-gen
okay we didn't have these same ideals
there's a big correlation between
Millennials and boomers okay but we're X
Gen X Gen x' more we made everybody
we're kind of like Zoomers the new
Zoomers are actually kind of more like
as they're late laughing [ __ ] more like
a Zoomer right because I mean well I
think they even like pegged s is that at
the time like as being like super
cynical yeah yeah but that's true yeah
that we knew they were lied to us I
don't mind that stereotype because in my
case that's entirely we knew they were
lied to us I hate everybody and I'm said
we didn't [ __ ] believe what they're
talkin in a way like I hate everybody
and I hate everything but I'm also like
kind of like weirdly optimistic as well
you see that releases your ability to
love everything because you know it's
all fake anyway yeah just take it for
what that's a good way of putting it
yeah so I can like kind of like in a way
I feel like I can love things on their
own levels yeah yeah yeah yeah well like
we were talking about before like I
think on our and actually way that how
are we recording this I'm not really
sure but what I'm one of our movie
reviews we were talking about how much I
loved sergeant pepper's Lonely Hearts
yeah and um and you know what I mean and
I was like look objectively I know that
that's a terrible movie and yet somehow
like I still love it and yeah that's
like it's not even a guilty pleasure cuz
I'm not guilty about it yeah I just love
it so ironically yeah it's like it's not
even ironic yeah I love the [ __ ]
pirate movie mmm which was like the
shitty like Kristy McNichol wasn't it
remember Popeye that was a shitty movie
that I liked that wasn't Robin Williams
right yeah bye
I only saw that one time I think yeah
and Shelley Duvall was in it was olive
oil that was some perfect casting right
there stupid [ __ ] although I love okay
I'll go back and watch Blue Lagoon and
love this that was also good I liked
yeah yeah we got a revisit Blue Lagoon
winsome when's the last time someone has
mentioned Blue Lagoon
I can't that was I think that might have
almost been wouldn't that almost be
child porn by today's standards it's
it's gating the line skating them ah
yeah I was reaching you don't wanna be
watching the other day it's on to be if
anybody wants to watch it for free was
Flowers in the Attic yeah which was
based on the book and actually they
toned the movie down quite a bit from
the book because I remember reading the
book when I was a kid and being like
yeah Jen says nice like brother and
sister kind of getting it on there I
mean they're trapped in an attic they
have anybody else so I can understand
that whatever was that other one that
uh-oh what's her name was in Hubert
shield yeah Brooke Shields pretty baby
pretty baby that was chesternut child
porn right there yeah I think she might
have only been 12 yeah no strip job
right there I mean I can't remember but
I'm pretty sure that was a bad bit
controversial yeah there was that was
when it was okay to exploit children
yeah
their goal was like whatever no big
there was no PC bag there I mean in some
ways it's better the people care
nowadays yeah [ __ ] a 12 year old
that's not gold yeah the whole idea was
is the [ __ ] was wrong and [ __ ] you that
was the idea pretty much it was wrong
man and you know what that could be the
entire like mission statement of the
1970s 70s was [ __ ] balls well have
pretty much sums it up yeah that pretty
much sums it up alright so
like I said this guy Eddie Leon ski
quote unquote the Brennan strangler I
didn't even know about him until I saw
him linked at the bottom of the
Wikipedia article about the blackout
strangler because they were like hey
here was another guy that did the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] on another continent now
this guy was actually an American he was
born in 1917 in New Jersey he was the
sixth child of Russian born immigrant
parents John Lansky who was a stevedore
I think and his wife Amelia they moved
to New York City when Eddie was a baby
now after he left high school or junior
high school in 1933 he went on a
secretarial course finished in the top
10% of his class so it was in a dummy he
had a bunch of like clerical jobs worked
at a grocery store stuff like that now
eventually in 1941 he got called up for
military service now his family it
should be said was not a super happy
situation this wasn't a situation like
Gordon Cummins where you know as much as
they know about his childhood background
it seemed fairly normal or even fairly
affluent this family not so much there
was like a lot of kids the dad was very
abusive and an alcoholic and actually
died fairly young of alcohol related
illnesses the mother also had some
mental problems undisclosed what they
were I'm not really sure what they were
yeah she crazy um yeah I guess so um
some of his two of his brothers actually
ended up in prison or you know were
actually had other criminal records and
he had another brother that ended up in
a mental asylum
crazy ass family now yeah so this was a
guy where like I said it's not
justifiable obviously but it's more
understandable when it's somebody that's
coming out of a situation like this
rather than it just kind of coming out
of thin air
so um his mother actually I guess after
his father died she remarried another
guy which was also abusive and so you
know that didn't go well now the young
Eddie Leon ski was um he had kind of
like a weird almost like a Norman Bates
like Riya
relationship with his mother it's like
he got picked on like he he was like
really close to her you know in the
sense that like even like kids at school
would pick on him for being a mama's boy
because he was like so close to his mom
and stuff but then on the other hand he
also seemed to hate her and want to kill
her and in some types of serial killers
that seems like a pretty common like
psychological dichotomy going on there
I'm not like you know I haven't like
looked it up or anything but that seems
like something that goes on a lot that
like they're very that's why I say it's
like a Norman Bates kind of it's like a
love-hate relationship with their mother
and because it's a love/hate
relationship with their mother they kind
of extend that to love-hate relationship
with women and they almost want to
punish all women because of the
perceived failings of their mother weird
so I feel like there's kind of some of
that going on in this case as well now
something about Eddie Leon ski just like
Gordon Cummins who is The Blackout River
this guy also um you know big dude
muscular dude you know who's tall
good-looking
you know blond hair he was a you know
they called him I've seen him actually
called the smiling psychopath because
most pictures that you see of him he
looks like he's got this wide smile he
looks super friendly he doesn't look
creepy in the least he just looks like a
normal dude and a lot of people at the
time said you know he was um real
outgoing a real friendly role gregarious
they said he's something like um he's a
little narcissistic he was very worried
about his physical appearance he was
very into weight lifting physical
appearance all that type of stuff so he
was always like worried about he looked
like and he was always um performing
like something that he would do was he
would go in a bar and he was like you
know buy everyone drinks and stuff and
then he would like you know try to like
arm-wrestle dudes or he would like jump
up on the bar and like walk on his hands
like handstands and stuff like that so
he was like don't walk yeah he was like
a show-off type of dude like I said like
narcissistic now he joined the military
in 1941 now initially he was stationed
with the 52nd Signal Battalion in San
Antonio Texas now at this point he
starts to drink heavily
his dad had also done and becomes kind
of an alcoholic and he sort of became
known for drinking whiskey and like
putting all this weird [ __ ] in it like
he would put like hot peppers in it or
he would put like mustard in it or
ketchup or like he would put like weird
condiments in there and drink it can I
prove what a bad yeah like as a show-off
eat it like I said he had a very
show-off II like very loud type of
personality and you know he was like I
said he would jump up on the counters
like walking his hands and all this kind
of the kind of [ __ ] now it seems like
around this time that you know there are
kind of like rumors that he attempted to
either rape and or strangle a woman and
this was while he was still in Texas
like I said he was originally from New
Jersey but he didn't really get um
prosecuted for like nothing really
happened at the time I'm not sure if she
didn't press charges or if they just
thought it was no big deal or whatever
but you know what I mean it was kind of
swept under the rug now in 1942 they
shipped him off to Australia now at this
point in the war um the Australians were
kind of like you know worried about a
attacks from the Japanese and various
other things so there was like this kind
of setup thing where they were gonna
ship some American soldiers over they'll
like help them out if they needed it or
whatever so a bunch of American soldiers
were arrived in Australia at the time
now from everything that I've heard and
read and I actually listened to a couple
of podcasts about this like a couple
that were done by a couple of
Australians and one that'd by a guy that
had written a book about this dude and
they and who was also Australian so he
was talking about how at the time there
was some resentment towards the American
servicemen who were serving in Australia
at the time they had all that money
yeah and that was one of the reasons
they said the American soldiers were
much better paid than their Australian
counterparts had much nicer uniforms you
know the Australian which had that
accent they yeah they had the accent and
they said that the Americans actually
largely had better manners than the
Australians
very a genteel they addressed everyone
is sir and ma'am and like a lot of
people liked that a lot of women liked
how polite they were how much money they
had you know they'd seemed very friendly
and outgoing and stuff which the
Australian soldiers kind of like they
didn't like that so much because they're
like hey we don't have any money over
here and perhaps they were not as
quote-unquote refined as they perceived
the Americans to be it was actually kind
of the same in the England too though
any American soldiers were popular in
England they yeah they were overpaid and
overseas oversexed and over here there's
a stereotype that Americans are [ __ ]
kind of old fishing actually an American
it depends on person I was in the army
and American soldiers were [ __ ]
popular everywhere we went
hey let me tell you the number one place
where we were [ __ ] superstars Israel
really oh yeah we were in Israel we were
[ __ ] superstar I hooked up with a
female Israeli paratrooper
it was [ __ ] I ain't gonna [ __ ] go
down now those good-looking those people
treated us like [ __ ] Kings harassment
oh we were you know I'm we were in Korea
we do you know I even went to Germany no
best art was ever treated was in Israel
yeah it's awesome and [ __ ] we were on
our best behavior yeah
Korea would make you act bad but Israel
what there was you know they they
treated you with respect
they treated you as if you were walking
on the moon like they came at you like
you're a respectable person so you you
responded in kind
yeah and at that time you know we had
given them a bunch of jet fighters and
we had a bunch of you know support going
to them they [ __ ] all we got along
[ __ ] great I was hanging out with
[ __ ] dudes that had served into Gaza
stripped and you know and you know you
know dudes that were doing some heavy
duty [ __ ] combat patrols through Gaza
and then they were [ __ ] cool by
drinks all night long oh yeah one thing
that is real good troops man real good
truth
and you know we tell you you know some
people some people in America might kind
of think well Israel in Israelis they
must be kinda like Jewish Americans
they're not it's a totally different
culture they're from another country
when you when you meet them they're just
in those days they were very macho they
were kind of a lot like Americans in a
certain way and say you know and then
you know most of most of the guys had
served in some kind of a military
function in their country so when you
dealt with an Israeli you were dealing
with him an ex-military guy so you know
I mean you were coming at him like yeah
and under the radio there's no they
can't see what I'm doing but he's doing
this I'm pointing at your eyes yeah it's
like a high ball thing yeah exit
everybody was ex-military so one thing
that one thing that kind of fascinated
me when I was researching these two
cases was the difference in perception
between American servicemen in England
and in Australia so it's like funny that
in England they thought they were
boorish oaths and yet in Australia they
thought they were like super polite
which is very funny to me some like the
truth is probably someone well you know
comparatively Australians are pretty
close to Americans in it I've always
like kind of thought of them that way
yeah they're closer to Americans than
wow I'm pretty sure I don't know about
that cuz I know you're also married guys
in Australia and live down there for a
while they loved it yeah I feel like in
a lot of ways Australian culture is very
similar to Western culture they like hot
rods and similar history all my history
they even kind of had cowboy I mean they
have they had an Aboriginal okay the
thing that we're just plays just like
they here yeah they have a similar it's
kind of closer yeah so I kind of feel
like culturally they're coming from a
more similar place yeah and they're like
quote unquote a newer country now you
know your ethnic group might have
something to do with it but maybe not
because
you know and the main [ __ ] I don't
know it's I kind of feel like the
country where you grew up or where you
went to school like is more influential
than the family that you came from
I feel like probably because you know
I'd see some [ __ ] go down between you
know African American US soldiers and
foreigners you know the mean and you
could definitely tell that people were
from different cultures in different
[ __ ] countries I'm used to be there
to understand what I'm talking about you
know what I mean like a lot of you don't
know this but African American soldiers
were super popular and they were always
super popular in Germany oh yeah
actually I heard the women yeah I've
heard that black dudes know how to run
game on German girls okay they're you're
offering something and German guys don't
have in a certain way you ever mean now
bringing them back to the United States
didn't work out too well all the time
you know with some of these marriages
because you know German American girl
HTV German girls say they don't want to
live in a hood you know I mean so you
better be living in a nice place because
those girls are kind of pampered you
know to me but as far as human to human
interactions no african-americans
running game on German girls this is
[ __ ] I thought that I knew another
this another guy that actually was
served in Germany and yeah yeah he said
watch out BBC comedy yeah so yeah like I
said I thought that was very interesting
that there there was a lot of um you
know it's a not like overt resentment
but there was some kind of like you know
Australian soldiers like looking at
American soldiers like man they got
nicer [ __ ] they got more money they have
more money to like go out clubbing and
like take girls out to dinner and like
good Rasta toots and stuff and they were
kind of resemble that they didn't have
that so into this you know mix comes
Eddie Leon ski now he arrives in
Melbourne Australia in February of 1942
which if you will remember was exactly
the same time that [ __ ] Gordon
Cummins was doing his [ __ ] in England
who was in February so Leon ski gets to
Australia in February now he is sent to
camp Pell which is Royal Park pretty
much as soon as he got there he started
getting in trouble cuz like I said he
was an elk
just like his dad was he started [ __ ]
drinking and they also uh uh he also
allegedly tried to rape a woman in st.
kilda now her name I believe was Doreen
Justice he tried to rape her she fought
him off he left some of his clothing in
her apartment
and she later turned that over to police
she had also seen him naked so she
reported to police that he had a very
distinctive mole on his penis no that
was something they would identify him
later on at this point they're not
really looking for him because like I
said this is just an attempted rape just
an accepted rape but you know what I
mean like consider in light of what he
would do later whatever so he um kind of
gets in trouble for that just for being
like drunk and obnoxious in public he
gets thirty days in the stockade but got
released nothing really came of it but
then he started like [ __ ] in another
[ __ ] drinking binge
now May the 3rd 1942 like I said this is
only a few months after [ __ ] Gordon
Cummings was Gordon comments was doing
that [ __ ] in England May the 3rd there's
a woman named mrs. ivy McCloud and she
was found murdered in in a like a store
doorway
next to the Bleak House Hotel in Albert
Park in Melbourne now this crime was
immediately called a brownout crime now
like I said Australia they didn't have
their their wartime stuff wasn't as
stringent as England I mean England was
like no street lights everybody's paint
their windows black or put curtains up
note like no lights whatsoever
whereas Australia had more like a
brownout type of thing where they were
like well we'll just put on every other
street light just keep your lights low
like you don't Stearn them completely
off but let's kind of just keep it sort
of darkish or dim just so the just in
case the Japanese decide to attack so
maybe they won't be able to sees of it
so it wasn't quite as dark as England
but similar so like I said that's why
they call them too Brown strength so but
they initially they really you know
immediately called this a brownout crime
so six days after this first one which
was Ivan MacLeod he kills another woman
who was 31 years old her name is Pauline
Thompson this was on May 9th now she had
been in a club or a bar whatever and she
was seen in the company of an American
servicemen so obviously he was in his
uniform because people identified him as
such
now they found her strangled to death
the following morning
now a weird thing that he would do he
didn't mutilate them necessarily he
didn't even rape them but something that
he would do is he would kill them and
then he would take their clothes off and
like pose them so that whoever found
their body like had to look right at
their like he would spread their legs
out so like whoever laid like a buffet
yeah like so whoever found the body
would have to be like confronted with
hey female genitalia right there in your
face yeah like that is common actually
in a lot of Auster it is they tend to
leave the victim in a compromising
position to humiliate her like yeah
supposedly humiliate who knows what
they're actually what a serial killer is
actually thinking at the time but might
be might be there
I kind of feel like that and like I said
I'm their standards are different so you
know it's hard lamb was taken and I can
see why always profiling because they're
sexualizing the victim because most of
us hopefully are not serial killers so
it's hard to get inside that mindset I
mean all you can do is like
intellectually try to I don't justify
not justify what they're doing but like
just trying to in like intellectually
get a handle on it I don't really think
the emphasis is on humiliation of the
victim I think it's more about the
sexual ization of the bigger yeah yes I
know they're trying to show the witness
what they saw that's what I think it
could be that yeah it's like look maybe
they're trying to make the people that
find it like see what they see what they
saw wait damn yeah check out how hot
like yeah that might be that that might
vary
I think it's more along that like I said
I think it's harder for like a
quote-unquote normal person to like
understand me because the serial killer
I mean obviously that's like way off the
[ __ ] charts of like look how hot she
is that's why I didn't yeah probably
what they're like now they'll understand
now they'll understand me because
they'll see what I'm coming from even
though everyone's just like what the
[ __ ] my yeah yes yeah that's horrifying
but yeah so that was something that he
tended to do like I said he didn't
really rape them or mutilate them the
way Gordon Cummins did but he would
definitely like pose them in a way that
implied that he was trying to display
them in wrong way so yes so as I said
Polly Thompson was the next victim she
was 31 she had been seen with a young
man in a American servicemen uniform and
also I guess people had seen her in a
bar and they heard the guy talking and
they said he had an American accent so
they figured like from the job that he
was an American servicemen now the next
one happened um a little more than a
week later it was May 18th like I said
the last one was May 9th this was a 40
year old woman named Gladys Hosking now
she was I'm not sure if she was a
prostitute or not but she was just like
walking through the street one night
minding her own beeswax near Melbourne
University and when they found her later
on she was same thing she'd been naked
and posed she was like all covered with
mud now in this particular night um a
guy later reported to police that a
disheveled American man had come up to
him out of breath and asking for
directions and this person noted that
the guy's uniform was covered with mud
just as Gladys Hoskins body had been
found so there was that whole thing now
just as in the case of Gordon Cummins
this guy thankfully you know this
happened only over a couple-week period
um he was caught pretty much immediately
because he didn't seem to be making any
particular secret of what he was doing
or who are trying to hide it or anything
like that it's like he's leaving bodies
pretty much in the open
he's letting himself be seen with these
victims so it doesn't seem like he's
like some big [ __ ] mastermind or
anything like that just like this is
like somebody that's again taking
advantage of a situation just like the
guy in the first case um I don't know if
I mentioned it before but he was only 22
or 23 years old at the time so at this
stage so he killed three women in just a
couple weeks and he was pretty much
picked up immediately because one
witness very famously said it's a guy
that walks on his hands and Eddie Leon
ski was very famous for walking around
on handstands like showing off like he
did like he would go in bars and he
would walk in his hands and stuff like
that so people pointed out to him him to
police like pretty quickly and he had
also left a couple of his rape victims
or attempted rape victims alive so there
were several several witnesses that were
able to identify him so when police like
suspected who it was they kind of got
all these people together like they did
a lineup of a bunch of American
servicemen I believe one of the
witnesses was even the aunt of one of
the first women that had been attacked
but hadn't been murdered
like the first attempted rape and she
immediately like pointed to him and said
yeah that's him he's pretty distinctive
looking like I said it's I have pictures
of him
it's creepy because it's creepy because
he doesn't look creepy he just looks
like a regular friendly it's like you
know he's blond hairy Bill muscular dude
he's gonna be a little smile it's like
he just looks like a regular guy so he
pretty much immediately got arrested and
charged with three murders now because
there was so much I'm you know I'm not
gonna say assume that it was like super
attention or anything like that but
there was kind of some conflict between
how they were gonna charge him it's like
were they gonna charge him by like
American military rules were they charge
them by Australian rules because he had
killed Australian women so there was
kind of some controversy there about how
he was going to be punished or put on
trial or whatever
they decided that that he would be tried
by a United States court-martial
now they initially tried to portray him
as not fit to stand trial on the basis
of insanity and they tried to do that by
saying oh look at all this crazy [ __ ] he
drinks like he puts [ __ ] hot peppers
and his whiskey it's like crazy shits up
well he says all this crazy [ __ ] and
also and I'm not sure where he got this
from but when they asked him what his
justification was he would say that he
wanted these women's voices he had a
thing for women's voices and I think
that when they kind of looked back into
his history I guess he had a thing where
his mom used to sing to him in this kind
of high-pitched voice and he was kind of
into that and not at the same time I was
like I have a weird thing and but no but
like I said but sometimes when he would
get drunk yeah he would start to sing in
this really like a high-pitched woman's
voice like a lunatic yeah and so but I'm
not sure I'm not sure like how truthful
this was because it should be noted that
there was a movie out at the time might
have been dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde I'm
not really sure but there was a plot
point in it where like one of the
villains was like oh I'm gonna kill her
and take her voice or whatever so I feel
like he might have gotten it from that
or maybe not I'm not really sure I think
he [ __ ] it does really seem like
that but it seemed like he did say that
that was a big thing that he would say
he's like I was trying to he's like I
loved their voices so much that I wanted
to take them that I wanted to keep them
that was one thing and I don't know if
he was just trying to get an insanity
he's trying to gain his sanity please
because he would say that he was a
real-life Jekyll and Hyde he said that
he's trying he's trying to get an
insanity plea he's trying to paint an
image to the public that he's some kind
of disturbed guy and that you know what
I mean he had a higher motive
yeah no it was about the [ __ ]
that's what yes he was killing him
you know he was killing yeah and it
should be noted that one of his early
victim even the voices attracted him he
thought that was hot yeah but that's not
why he was doing it
you know I mean he you want to have sex
with him and wanted to kill him
afterwards that's what it is it's just
that simple
and you know I mean he's not gonna go in
front of jury of people and say you know
I mean I want to get my rocks off I
wanted to have sex think she was hot and
[ __ ] what I'm through and then yeah
when I'm busting another I like to see
him die he's gonna say that yeah even
though that's what it is that's [ __ ]
up but that's probably true it's like
it's probably no more complicated it's
not that complicated and it's like and I
should be noted to that one of his early
victims who had his one of his attempted
rape victims I believe who actually
survived
she said that he sent to her you know
when she was walking on the street he
said something to the effect of I feel
like strangling a dame and you're as
good as any yeah well you know I mean
it's not like he wants to go through
this whole rigmarole of dating somebody
having sex with an employee cannot isn't
what's - its work it's better just bring
her to just break them let them oh you
can't let him live after that so you
choke him out yeah and then that becomes
part of the whole ritual choking them
out and watching them die becomes part
of the whole experience then this can't
cheat on you after that cuz she's dead
so in a way it's kind of like owning
them can I just um can I just interject
right here I got me a girlfriend raped
her killed her and then she's not
cheating on me up of this can I just
interject right here that dudes thought
processes are very different from mine
yeah the last one she ever that's a very
different this yeah like [ __ ] sometimes
[ __ ] that he says like he's not a serial
killer does that I know hmm but um you
know him by now yeah yeah yeah he's not
a serial killer but he can kind of get
into there like because like some of the
[ __ ] he says I'm like it honestly that
would never occur to me yeah yeah that's
not
this is a very yes there's nothing to
kurtis it's like that the [ __ ] would you
even think of that it's a very male
behavior that he's doing this is why
this is we know women don't do this this
is a male thing this is why we don't
this is testosterone we don't need you
in the hands of them this is a
testosterone the effects of testosterone
and the men in the in in in the hands of
it ooh
but intermesh you know talking about
yeah a [ __ ] subhuman in the man this
is what would an under man you know an
inferior man and with certain ways he
doesn't want to go through all that day
is like every time like a duty because
squeeze out to me I just want to miss
them the reason why he doesn't want to
go through it is cuz he would lose if he
had to go through all that you know he's
not gonna win against [ __ ] healthy
guys so he's just gonna go talk some
chick he's attractive gonna rape her and
then he's gonna kill her up because he
gets what he wants regardless
Zak and then he doesn't tell you with an
after exact cuz it's just a woman that's
what his thinking is this thing is it's
just that we don't know really mattered
him II mean I mean he's got a bust a nut
what does it have to do and that's all
what I said happens it's all that that's
yes the miss adjusts the world
it's just that stupid and it's just that
simple yeah that's what like
intellectually I know what you're saying
but like you know it always like
depresses me we yeah whatever we gonna
do these conversations like yeah it's
like like no offense to do that list of
the show it's like like I have some like
beautiful wonderful like friends that
are dudes and I'm always have this is a
little jitters though in general I have
kind of a Dimpy this is not my dudes
though this is not that's true but I I
don't know I kind of feel like that is
Vikram it's a spectrum even dudes that
aren't serial killers like even a cup
couple down from that it's still not
like fun to do this is the extreme end
of the spectrum though well duh yeah I
mean it's so I don't have any [ __ ]
mercy for the dudes
you see I hear all these [ __ ]
programs and people trying to [ __ ]
psychoanalyze and in awake
almost kind of glorify or you know I
mean or kind of like glamorized these
serial killers as if there's some kind
of a Hannibal Lecter almost kind of like
anti superhero or something yeah that's
not what these are I don't like that
these are dudes trying to come yeah
that's all it is like I love some OC
they're not like [ __ ] Hannibal Lecter
said that is a phenomenal character yes
most serial killers are dumb
[ __ ] they're rapists yeah
they're just stupid animalistic you're
right like some of them are cunning sure
and they get away with it for a long
time but they're not smart they're not
compatible they're not like there's
nothing like that dude's a rapist
because why would they have to do that
otherwise if they were really smart or
competent or cool or anything they
wouldn't have to like do this kind of
crap they're rapists yeah I'm just gonna
rape them rape a woman yeah okay because
they can't just in a way they can't get
it any other way like I said in a way
they're afraid of women they're like
intimidated by women they know that they
can't get over your already complex and
stuff that's exactly what and then the
struggle of all this rape okay the
backlash and the emotional charge of all
this rate mixed with murder becomes part
of the experience you know dama yeah
it becomes merged with sex well yeah
issues they feel like they don't have
any control over their own life they
don't have any controller or women they
don't have any control over what other
people are doing so they have to impose
it right and now once they're caught
they're not gonna say this to the
authorities of course they're gonna have
to make up another explanation because
because what's really going on is
[ __ ] embarrassing yeah I heard these
voices and the souls called out yeah I
was like Ursula and the Little Mermaid
and I had to like steal her boys cuz
yeah beautiful really what happened was
is that he saw some chick that he wasn't
that he couldn't get by any other
legitimate means so he overtook her by
violence and he used her as jerk-off
material all right and then killed her
so she wouldn't rat him out
yeah and that was that was the
experienced and that became part of the
whole that was the experience that he
got
it's like a third-rate sexual experience
it yeah and I feel like that might be
like yeah there are some exceptions like
because I do feel like there are some
serial killers that some other like
super weird [ __ ] going on but I think
like your most your one is average
though run-of-the-mill serial Heroes
like 80 90 percent of your serial
killers other than the ones that have
like a really really really bad problem
sitting like really [ __ ] up like
necrophilia and [ __ ] that's a whole
other issue but um most of your serial
killers most of the even people that do
like one or two off like dudes that I've
written about that even they never
caught I feel like all they're doing is
it's an opportunistic thing it's like oh
I'm a truck driver and I was like
driving on the highway I saw a
prostitute and then more like
masturbation because it isn't like that
because the woman wasn't into it no so
you were on your own dude yeah you might
as well just use your hand yeah you know
my man Hanna [ __ ] least you don't
have to kill your yeah after we use your
hand in a damn video screen they have
all this lights you know we right you're
dealing with [ __ ] dudes that their
sexuality is not well developed yeah
that's enough that's exactly what webs
another state I mean damn they're not
successful and that's what I mean I and
that's the problem I have like I said as
fascinated I am as I am with like true
crime and serial killers and stuff like
that I do feel like there's a problem
with glamourizing them or like make them
seem like cool or anything but most of
people are just they're scumbags it's
like there's a scumbags it's like they
can't get laid like by normal me and so
they have to like force it like you said
it's not these aren't like dudes you
want to like look up to you know there's
nothing badass about no the closest one
to a dude that might have been suitable
to be a saint boyfriend private in Bundy
and he had a girlfriend he had a
girlfriend but he's tried to report him
but they didn't listen to but that would
have been a superficial relationship
because he kind of had that damn
psychopathic well he had that right now
the only personality was kind of like a
pathological liar stuff - real real
superficial which to me that he's not
really able to have a
in ship so he did what he did because
that was the only way he could get it
done yeah yeah I mean to me that's
scarier because he couldn't enjoy
anything other than that this is all
very superficial for that this is not to
be scarier because like I said you know
a lot of dudes that end up serial
killers are you know if they kill two
three four women you know most of them
are creeps and like yeah you know you
would avoid them if you you know came
across that if you're just like walking
down the street and you saw them you'd
probably like run away but somebody like
Ted Bundy that's why he's so dangerous
is because he seemed so normal and some
of them do like and I feel like those
are the ones and most dangerous and
that's what makes me like not to trust
anybody because like you don't know like
it's that normal person cuz look how
long like he was doing that [ __ ] and his
girlfriend didn't know yeah I mean she
did report him early on like she didn't
know but she was like suspicious she
knew something was up with a guy she
knew something was weird and she's like
oh he has the same car and he looks like
that so I mean you know fair play to her
that she reports always gonna be kind of
a certain dimension missing out of these
guys yeah to where you're like this
isn't right why is this gonna do what
this guy doesn't react like other people
yeah there's always like a dimension
missing from their personality in terms
of emotions I mean you know I can see it
yeah and I've seen it in a lot of dudes
and it's always a guy who's a [ __ ]
pathological liar yeah pathological
lying and a person that [ __ ]
constantly lies and tries to be
something that they're not they are not
all serial killers but also guys are
like that all serial killers have that
person is a huge red flag right right I
mean anybody that can't be like
completely honest with writer can't
write alright I feel like somebody that
anybody that can't like if they have
some kind of weird like emotional thing
where they can't like oh they're trying
to be somebody that or they're trying to
be something that's all part of
pathological lying it's it's they're
trying to be more than what they are and
they're constantly trying to make a fake
error about themselves that's them
yesiree killers all have that well
people like that are not serial killers
but seriously but all
pretty much yeah well you'd have to
because like I said even people that are
like scumbags like you know [ __ ]
whatever and they're serial killers but
even they have families and stuff like
that that are always like surprised when
they get caught so they obviously have
some kind of like
normal veneer yeah they seem like some
dude that gets caught hey he murdered
like 10 20 women or whatever over 20
years and they just now caught him do
you ever see like people ask his family
members or neighbors they're like yeah I
knew that [ __ ] yeah they never
say that they never do mmm
they never say that and I don't know if
it's because like family members are
like blinded you don't want they're
blinded you don't want to know that
you're you know that your family member
is a serial killer always keep an eye
out for a person who's very superficial
and always putting on airs yeah trying
to [ __ ] roleplay they always seemed
like a damn live-action a larper don't
know how to be a real [ __ ] they're
always like that too they're trying to
be a Roper they can't be themselves
because there is no self yeah it's like
there's something missing so there
always seemed to be kind of like LARPing
yeah that's what they're doing right
yeah that's what they're doing they
don't there's no there there there's
like that or they know enough to know
that what they really are what in court
is [ __ ] up right and they know that
they'll be caught if they show that so
everything about them is a front it's an
artifice yeah everything and a wise
person can spot it yeah I mean I'm not
like wise person good I don't like want
to [ __ ] at people on [ __ ] on people at
Dell because no mostly never yeah most
people are not equipped with the
defenses that you need in order to spot
it but if you watch enough serial
killers okay and you have a good idea if
you watch enough serial killers their
interviews you can see that there's a
vibe you can feel it oh it's like
they're LARPing yeah you know meaning
that there's not much to them they're
very superficial and shallow you will
see people like that in your lives those
people are not all serial killers most
of them are not but it's probably every
serial killer has that vibe to of them
yeah they just do because I'm always
saying like like ice
I'm not saying everybody like this Eric
hill obviously they're not all centers
you have that for centage but and I'm
saying this particularly to women
because I know women have like a big
thing about like not trusting their
instincts you know but if you're a
rounded dude and like everything about
she's going man get away from this dude
get away go dude because there is some
reason why it's like even if you don't
know you can't just find it's just like
it's too many lies jam up too much of a
[ __ ] fake front you know I mean that
should all be warning signs yeah you
know and like I said like you can't like
blame victims all the time because some
dudes are really really good and they're
manipulating other people and that has
happened in many cases there are other
kind of Psychopaths and bad guys that
are not serial killers and they're not
sexually motivated doing other things
but you know when you're talking about a
serial killer always remember that where
you're dealing with is a serial rapist
they just happen to kill people to
silence the witness yeah and then the
killing of the people to size the
witness becomes part of the experience
that they look for it so it's a sexual
orientation but these [ __ ] are
not normal they're like they're like
they're almost kind of autistic in a way
you know well not to [ __ ] on you [ __ ] on
testing because most autistic people
don't they don't do that but I'm well I
don't think any offices you know blood
beverage penetrates it's a personality
what he calls well there's a tiny char
it's a personality I mean and I'm not
saying like because serial killers come
in a couple different flavors
yeah and now there's like there's a
couple different types yeah and almost
all of them are addictive personalities
too they have addictions and stuff and
if they like something that's good and
they'll just keep doing it over and over
yeah almost all of them which like I
said that weird to me - it's all part of
their behavior they're all jackoff
artists - you know peeping tom types a
lot I do start like a to keep their
hands off themselves and [ __ ] you know
the way they are well like I said I feel
like this dude um you know the brownout
strangler Eddie Leon ski he kind of
started out like I said
black out Ripper Jordan Cummins like I
said you don't really have much of a
history this type of thing it seemed
like oh just the war and he just kind of
like okay I'm just gonna kill
everybody's a lot we don't know about
but yeah like I said a lot of his
history is not known he doesn't have a
criminal record so the guarantee he was
a dude kind of like [ __ ] other serial
killers well fake like after they caught
him and hanged him um
Scotland Yard looked into it and there
were a couple of unsolved murders that
happened in 1941 like a year like a few
months before and they thought maybe he
might have done those as well so it
wasn't kind of like he probably had a
similar back it wasn't proven but in a
similar childhood Bundy or who else you
know the guy who killed all the [ __ ]
dudes well there was a lot of Jeffrey
Dahmer daumer daumer yeah this guy kind
of like that probably yeah yeah I'm not
gay straight every time they catch one
of these [ __ ] they have so much
[ __ ] in common well and I kind of feel
like they probably did a lot of [ __ ]
earlier yeah didn't get caught for or
they ridiculous oh well yeah like
particularly back in this like
particularly this [ __ ] that happened
back in the 40s when one it was during
wartime - you know it was old-timey that
MDNA or anything like that so I kind of
feel like maybe they did a lot of [ __ ]
that they got away with they got away
with it and no one linked them to it
typically these guys start [ __ ] up
around puberty yeah I kind of feel like
am i smart dude like must don't start
like minor [ __ ] teenagers like Breaking
and Entering peeping tom type [ __ ] an
animal tour animal torture that kind of
stuff [ __ ] are not [ __ ] up not
always but 90 90 95 percent [ __ ] up
other children maybe weird [ __ ] like
that
yeah it's like the acting out in school
like there's always like arson
bedwetting that's another thing
bedwetting and that's I don't know why
but it seems like a lot of serial
killers like dudes that end up as serial
killers we're bad way
and arsonists yeah although bedwetting
doesn't make you serial killer no but
I'm just saying that they said that they
have weird [ __ ] that's something that
almost all serial killers had I gotta
think bedwetting has something to do
with being molested and I think being
molested
maybe causes cervical reasons well
another thing too is that it might be
even if it's not molestation it might be
that like the kid is bedwetting and then
they get punished harshly for yes and
then that might be yes so that's like a
masochism right so that might contribute
to it also so it might not even be like
yeah I mean that and that might be like
a symptom of stress because they're just
like getting you haven't looked honest
all the time and then that makes them
like bed wet more because they're under
more stress involves if Freud would say
Maz involves his genitalia so it would
do that it's never really looked at much
into that but that could be it could be
the bedwetting and the punishment of
bedwetting would be kinda like
sadomasochism yeah and I feel yeah I
definitely feel like there's a need that
direction maybe yeah because there's
like an infertile ISM there it's like
especially if they get punished harshly
for it like some because you know how
like some parents back in the old days
we're like if your kid like what the bed
was like the weird guy Wadley like quasi
sexual kind of or they would make like a
huge deal about it and like so you see
you'd develop a complex so I kind of
feel like and I think we've mentioned on
the show before but it's like that's why
I think like this era of serial killers
like maybe doesn't happen in the same
way anymore because I feel like people
that had these like what is pretty
normal behaviors for kids like you know
little kids like jerk off little kids
pee in their beds oh yeah it happens but
it's like if you back in those days back
in those days they did like these weird
like super strict like punishments on
these children in it became a whole
thing yeah it makes sense and that would
like mess them up had not not to
demonize religions you don't I mean
because you know I got like religious
mythology but the way religions were
applied probably had a lot to do with
that
so I don't want to [ __ ] lay it at the
foot of
but people that took [ __ ] too far kid
what's a big [ __ ] deal
That's not me it's not that's I mean it
yeah I I kind of feel like that's a lot
of the thing and I feel like any time
that parents are overly strict
particularly on something that is
natural or is not all that controllable
especially by a kid if you come down
hard on your kid about that then that
kid is gonna be [ __ ] up pretty much
forever there's you know there's a
formative period you want to blow them
steaks off just let them ride this yeah
that's what I mean just like chill at
especially if it's like pee in their bed
it's not seriously cute she was probably
too scared to get up and take seriously
it's really not that big a deal yeah and
it's like I feel like yeah you you make
a huge deal about it then the kid is
gonna make a huge deal yeah and then
it's gonna become a huge deal later on
as like I said they don't all become
serial killers but it doesn't help for
blood especially if that kid was born
with like a proclivity to right and then
it starts to lead in this and it's gonna
just be a whole perfect so he might have
the wrong genes and right you did it
[ __ ] a minute that's my means act so as
parents just chill out yeah I mean
especially if it's a red natural like I
said kids pee they're big it's pee their
bed kids jerk-off yeah kids do weird
[ __ ] yeah sleepwalk they sleepwalk that
is like you know if your kid is gay if
your kid is what if just chill yeah
we're gonna sort of stuff it'll sort
itself out yeah don't be judgmental
[ __ ] about it and it'll all be
alright in the end hopefully you know
what I mean every now and then actually
those parents exist too much in the u.s.
I don't know I hope not back in the old
days yeah well they didn't know what
they were doing and they were literally
they were listening to other people who
didn't know what they were doing and
look what happened serial killer serial
killers all right now thanks a lot yeah
you shut it down no I'm just saying well
I have to say what happened to [ __ ] oh
really okay
and the show it's not over with I've
been drinking so edit Leon ski quote
unquote
yeah the brownouts Wrangler yeah he got
arrested like I said after only like a
couple of weeks of doing this [ __ ] so at
least they caught him right away
for the 1940s I was pretty good so he
confessed to the crimes they tried to
make it seem like he was crazy cuz it's
like I wanna steal women's voices and
all that kind of crap but no one bought
it even back then so he got convicted
sentenced to death by a general
court-martial on July 17th 1942 General
Douglas MacArthur himself confirmed the
sentence yes and signed the death
warrant kill that [ __ ] he did
yeah it was awesome yeah he personally
desired the execution order personally
he didn't do that like later on he like
fogged that off I'm like his secretary
or whatever yeah but in this case he
actually did do it now as far as I know
any Leon ski was only the second
American servicemen ever executed during
World War two so there's something there
so yeah he got a [ __ ] executed
commercial he deserved it though he did
yeah so even after he died they were
like that no one wanted to like [ __ ]
bury him anywhere they put him in like a
couple cemeteries in Australia like we
don't want him here they get some in the
ocean no okay I think he ended up buried
in Hawaii actually I'd like some [ __ ]
Schofield Barracks Post Cemetery I think
that's where they ended up but I've
thrown his ass overboard yeah now what
well someone say that burial sea of
course is an honor so maybe that means
no man sharks might eat you burial at
sea is honor you know maybe they didn't
want to do that crabs would eat you yeah
okay which okay I feed his ass to the
roaches hmm Oh rats
okay now as I said at the very beginning
of this segment that there was gonna be
like a surprise fun fact for mst3k fans
because I was very excited about this so
in 1986 they made a movie about Eddie
Lee on ski and it was called death of a
soldier and James Coburn starred in it
however
the actor that played Leon ski was
[ __ ] Reb Brown who's oh if you guys
saw like I said you mst3k fans if you
saw space mutiny it's [ __ ] blast hard
cheese the dude with the big [ __ ]
pecs it's like he's just like a super
bad actor he was in space me and he was
on mst3k
there's like probably my favorite
episode remember come on big mclarge
huge smash lamp there's a [ __ ] movie pun
speed chunk come on they made up like
all these funny there's like even a
t-shirt that has all the names they made
up about this [ __ ] dude because he
was like this big muscle head and he was
like a terrible actor yeah red Brown
played this [ __ ] serial killer in the
movie about a serial killer in 1986 and
now I have to [ __ ] see this I watched
the trailer on YouTube but I haven't
seen the trailer so that delighted me so
much and it like cheered me up after
reading about all this horrible murder
and mayhem you know so hopefully it
cheers you guys up and no no it's go
look it up rip steak face come on no
come on he doesn't know I saw that movie
but I was impressed you didn't know I
saw that movie that was a [ __ ] movie it
was but that won't that's why I got good
MST it was it was actually in my opinion
and like I said a lot of competition
area in my opinion that is probably peak
mst3k that is like the best Mystery
Science Theater episode it was like the
best synergy between his nerdy [ __ ]
I like MST but I don't have the [ __ ]
literary knowledge that you have I host
lino Leano Jim Knight takes place
I like musical humor and fart jokes and
[ __ ] he's not very no no I'm not I'm not
abated and I'm not elevated I mean I
like fart jokes too but what I I can
also I can also appreciate a good
Alexander Posey because I don't read to
really truly appreciate MST you have to
[ __ ] you have to know if there's a no
[ __ ] everything after Chumley's
joke's on what
the [ __ ] they talking about and I
have to sit like I'm not bragging or
anything but it's like you know I'm not
the smartest person we're all clearly
nerdy so that's probably like Stephen
Hawking yeah [ __ ] is so [ __ ] dirty
the smartest but even during the first
run of mst3k as obscure as most of the
references say but 99% of the references
I got yeah I had to look up maybe 1%
nerdy I've seen everything I've read
everything you have to have a [ __ ]
fast literary now I do to get all of
that I'm I don't I'm just a [ __ ]
common man I know I'm gonna common
mortal and they'll go off and I'm like
what the [ __ ] are they talking [ __ ] cool
man like I'll tell you what the nearly
there debate the new MST I like it
better because they dumped it down a lot
and they'll start [ __ ] dude if they
dumbed it down this don't do it's a
musical humor and start singing in the
old one-two um maybe you just don't
remember but see on the old one because
all of them grew up in the same era as
made like 60s and 70s so they refer a
lot to like old movies old commercials
like old TV shows that people are
forgotten about so I remember a lot of
that [ __ ] your own well no but like
early seventies and honestly when I was
growing up I was really interested
because my dad was like super into 60s
stuff in his sixties music and stuff so
I was really into like older stuff like
you when I was a kid so you know and I
read voraciously so I've kind of read
everything from every era so you gotta
be a real Brainiac to understand well
even if you don't like even if I don't
know exactly what they mean I'm like I'm
pretty sure what they're referring to
because I've heard of it before like
just you know through a thing right but
like I said ninety-eight ninety-nine
percent of the jokes I get yeah I'm like
25% 25% yeah yeah yeah I do like the new
one though yeah the new one the new and
I'm more like I don't know if they
dumbed it down you down the down one of
the UM references are more reef or more
recent that's what I'm saying they
dumbed it down because the new one I
could understand about 70
of it okay Sammy say the five percent of
it I get it but now you have all her
stuff I'm like you have to think to then
a couple like not a lot but like maybe
five percent of the references they made
on the old show are just [ __ ] they
understand because that's like inside
jokes yeah and I only know that cuz I
read their books right cuz I'm that much
of a dork
she loves that MST but yeah I could
watch that every day for the rest of my
life and I would be totally happy she
could and he picks on me about it but no
know how to pick on you but I let you
watch it I'm smart and I'm a nerd and I
don't care and anybody that like picks
on me about it
alright James shut it down we've
finished it for today right all right
okay I can't believe we like got we
ended up with [ __ ] talking about this
[ __ ] like you always how do we always
end up like talking about wave - it
doesn't matter we're talking about
[ __ ] Sarah it's just a show
is this a show I guess alright come
visit us again next week we'll be back
yeah we're not like I said we don't do
this we're no we're not okay
well here's the thing we recorded a
movie review we did similar but I think
we did it earlier but I don't think it's
going up until after this
so Tom complained at me last time yeah
and he's like outro we don't need to do
that whole outro cuz you do it the same
every time it's like everybody knows it
they're [ __ ] cooking out is good
we're patreon going all this like you
don't have to say oh yeah if you'd like
to show good support us on patreon or
sent us some [ __ ] PayPal PayPal
alright yeah there's a link in this if
you go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast at WordPress I go yeah and you
can find us on Facebook
yeah or find us on Facebook we're all
over the place just search 13 o'clock
podcast you'll find us you guys narrow
these yeah comment light and [ __ ]
please messages will share it with
people sure yeah
all right I'm [ __ ] up I'm actually
surprised that you're still barely
coping drinking [ __ ] because we have
recorded three show yeah
and drinking all night yeah you guys
want to know what Tom looks like when
he's [ __ ] that this is it if you're if
you're looking an audio podcast I was
just like this morning there it is like
you can't see it but you can imagine
just imagine ready I'm ready to finish
tonight all right
so actually we have to still go watch a
movie and then review another room Abby
Lee infinite been just watching it fall
asleep brother
well I we have to review it that I'll do
it okay this should be fun it's not
[ __ ] with me all right so that'll do
it for episode 153 about wartime serial
killers that happen like in the [ __ ]
darkness yeah they're both dead they
both got they both got I think got
caught immediately in exhale they were
dead exactly yeah so at least that
happened at least it wasn't a situation
where they never caught them up yeah no
they got off so yeah so hope you guys
enjoyed this if that's the word and we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]